[Music]
hey are we is it rolling we might be
drunk we're here we're queer happy
Holidays happy Quanza uh uh Hanukkah
festival of lights how you put Quanza
before Hanukkah wow white guilt tough
year I didn't uh it wasn't in Germany
I'm sure they put it
before so you're not hung over for once
and Mark is no no no that's not what I
meant when I said that Mark's very hung
over I said what's frightening is how
not hung over I am meaning I should be
ex the way I drank last night I should
be extraordinarily hung over and the way
I am bouncing back
from I don't know what to say man you
got alcohol lips I know those lips
that's a dry lip that's your body has no
moisture do you get the thing when
you're hung over cuz this has been
happen to me and it scares the [__] out
of me but yet it won't stop me yeah uh I
wake wake up like after night of
drinking like 6:00 a.m. my mouth is bone
dry and my heart is going like yes it's
going like wildly and I'm like oh my God
I'm so with you and it's nice to hear
that and then you just the anxiety is
looming and you can't go back to bed and
and then I'll sitting there going I got
married what did I do I know I give it a
year this is the saddest Santa of all
time wake up after a Coke Bender like
[__] Santa is falling off [__] bad
santa part three baby let's sad Santa s
Santa Santa oh it's pitching Bad Santa 3
sad Santa there you go dude by Z so you
went where did you drink well I own a
bar so whatever we had Mike Cannon guest
bartending last night what you actually
should come down and do that sometime
it's fun is he doing that badly is he
struggling that bad you wouldn't do that
I'll drink of your bar I don't want a
bartend yeah there for two hours and you
you you give out a there's you're trying
to get us to do free labor for you
there's a bartender back there with you
okay what do you Tim C a couple free
shots just a [__] party I'll tell you
what come back come in and drink and if
you feel like hopping back there and
pouring a drink you're allowed to he can
make a mean uh old fashion man yeah NE I
make the easy ones hey we uh yeah we had
Canon guest bartending and I went in to
hang out for that and then just oddly
like I a lot of friends started texting
me like hey are you are you the bar so
Brooks whan came by is he in town he he
he left today ah but he came by sagalo
came by my buddy Nick Simmons came by my
friends from this band The Dooms came by
like popping by W is this Jean Simmons
son yeah we're good friends how's the
tongue on the kit yeah I'm tell you the
way you said you were good friends were
so
aggressive we're very
close I didn't mean it like that uh yeah
but we're we're we're tight these days
who he brought me to one of the final
kiss shows wa that's pretty cool was
that a great show it was amazing we
stood against the stage
wow I was standing so close that I took
my drink and I went to set it down and I
almost put it on on the platform that
Jean Simmons like stood on and I was
like it was literally that it was wild
damn we had a blast do they still got it
kiss they killed wow they were kill dude
his dad's like still walking around
doing the tongue kicking like it's crazy
man remember when they had that reality
show for a minute yeah Family Jewels
yeah what was that like an Osborne
ripoff yeah like that kind of you know
when when every Rock family was doing
one of those things Shannon Tweed oh
love that Tweed I hung out with her
backstage whoa she still got it she's
still like gorgeous she was super cool
like I I I was like Nick can I tell your
mom that I I'm a big Frasier fan and I
love her episode of Frasier I remember
her Frasier episode she's an episode of
Frasier and uh he was like yeah tell her
and I go up to her and I go uh hey it's
so nice to meet you and I go I go I love
your episode of Fraser and she goes oh
shut shut the [__] up and I go wow I go
I'm serious I'm dead serious and we
started talking and then I go you raised
a really great kid Nick's a good kid and
she goes oh [__] off I love this woman
she was so ball Breaky yeah but we were
we were talking and laughing she was
great man she was great oh my Lord what
a Frasier is not what I would open with
personally that's my I love Frasier man
I was excited to meet somebody that was
on Fraser we're trying to get Kelsey
gramar on here and I feel like we we're
making some Headway right all right
we're trying we got to get him when he's
[__] housed then he'll say yes can I
please come in when Kelsey Grandma's
here please I'm getting Frasier tattooed
on my arm what you think I'm kidding no
I don't think you're kidding but that's
a crazy tattoo my favorite chit come of
all time I've seen your other tattoos I
believe you I'm getting ra tattooed my
beard I'm I'm dead serious I'm I'm
getting I'm getting the logo T what we
drinking by the way the wizard of Ros uh
today actually it's uh something that
you like the uh but uh brown butter fat
old fashion but this is like my little
take on it with a little clove like for
Christmas did you just turn that down I
don't want rum I'm out no no no no no
just take it give it a sip for the for
the sake of the holidays I got something
else for you pressure I felt that Jo Roa
flipping peer pressure on me W the
ultimate this is crazy I can't believeit
we have this on tape happy holidays guys
oh we can't get eggnog in this [__]
let's get some eggnog I can't have
eggnog I got a dairy thing sorry don't
worry we got Apple whiskey coming a bag
of coke last week you got have dairy all
right here we
go last week damn it that's how I should
have responded to that last night
to it's not bad it is tasty that's not
bad brown butter see this is how it
starts you know you say I'm not going to
drink today and then you're having a
cocktail 2 p.m. it's just to get over
the The Hangover then we're back for you
yeah for me I'm not hung over so it's
going to start the new oh yeah ball roll
well you might still have the the booze
flowing through your veins I got to see
Thanksgiving later oh with Tim Dylan oh
yeah I heard he's in it yeah yeah you're
a big horror movie guy yeah but I have a
pod I have a movie podcast called we'll
see you on hell I got we got to review
it tomorrow so I got to see I got to
actually go see it you guys got spots
tonight yeah yeah you guys last time I
was telling the story last night to
sagalo and Canon uh the last time I did
the show was when we did your bachelor
party and I J Dude I go it went for 4
hours I go I was so [__] up and then
goes I'm taking us all out to dinner at
Old Homestead we go to Old Homestead we
drink through dinner Stak we left I was
like I have to go home and you guys were
like come on come hang with us while we
do spots I was like I don't I go I
wouldn't walk in the club without spots
in the St man you guys went in and did
actual sets like I I was why would call
that an actual set that he went full
Kramer he was just in such a blackout
holy [__] man I was like this is amazing
to me yeah we did it well once you get
on that stage you kind of clear up a
little yeah yeah a little a little it
was it wasn't great yeah yeah I was
doing old jokes I couldn't think of my
new stuff it was bad I just started uh I
just started doing some spots again uh
because I haven't been doing them we
just been doing the road but starting to
rebuild City spots are tough man it's I
feel like the show is always running
behind or some [__] the time's always
getting cut it's hard to work on new
[__] so then you just force it in then
you you know but you don't want to eat
it either the best case scenario is all
like like I was at the stand on Monday
night I had a few Pops in me because I
did Legion of skanks and whatever I was
pretty [__] up but and then Aaron was
like you want to go on frantic and I was
like yeah sure and I just got to go up
do 10 minutes I worked on one new joke
had a great set I was like this is how I
always want to do it that's nice that
commitment on I start thinking on Monday
about the sets on Wednesday I'm like h
yeah God damn it man like it just hangs
over me I have that too with the the
avils you know the seller's like hey put
your veils in every week and on Sunday
or whatever the hell you put them in I'm
like I don't know I can't figure that
out two weeks ahead like like I don't
know where I'm going to be in two weeks
exactly the s's got that system where
it's like you put in this Wednesday for
the following Thursday through the
second Tuesday brain TST and then
remember when we used to do the
voicemail that was the one where I'm
like I remember Mark used to call and he
would just like We Were Young Comics
just dying for spots and Mark would be
like SD how are you go Yankees you know
kissing up for spots hav agila playing
in the background I was just trying to
play ball here yeah I remember she would
call you with your spots terrifying yeah
she would like now they just text it or
email it actually I didn't work there
when that was the system I worked there
in this new I didn't work there till
2019 really W what happened with you and
the seller nothing there's no what well
there's no there's a actually there is a
story in the book there we go you [__]
Dy no no no the uhome there was no I I
was always friends with the club Nome
and I had a had a weird thing where he
played like a prank on me he's the owner
this is getting pretty inside yeah sorry
he he played a prank on me and I got
very mad at him and I was like you know
what
dude like what and and it was it was
there was some tension for a few can we
hear the prank I wasn't working at the
club I was it was at a time in my career
where I would have very much liked to
have been working at the club I think I
had been passed and then I got it didn't
last very long I don't know I was just I
was just I wasn't where I wanted to be
uh in in the business and and and I
really wanted to be working there at
that time and
um
gnome if you see this gome we're all
good we're fine like I'm not telling the
story to disparage you in any way but
also to the viewers I'm not saying this
to disparage gnome oh boy just what
happened okay and he he apologized and
we're totally been fine for years spit
it out you
Egyptian I get a text
okay I'm at Gotham doing a spot and my I
I get off stage and you know you go sit
on those booths on side for me and I was
sitting there and I get a text and uh
it's it's from this it's something like
hey um we we had a Fallout or something
like that you know can can you come down
here and do a set and I was like
yes yes it like a Friday night I was
like yes yeah finally right so I
literally rushed to the cellar I'm all
excited I get there and gnome goes
there's no spot I just wanted to show
everybody your terrible tattoo oh and I
was like are you [__] kidding me dude
double zc not a good prank yeah I was
like are you kidding me and he was like
he's like come on we're bust come on we
bust pawns I was like you had a tattoo
of Niles yeah Kelsey grar
yeah he's a grammar Nazi and uh and uh
you know somebody tried to do that on a
on a TV show what's that grar forget the
guy's name the guy did that prank show
uh Ashton Kutcher the guy that's that's
the guy whose brother is the singer and
the Scissor Sisters he had a prank what
the [__] I know help anyway he had a
prank TV show and he tried to do a
sketch called grammar Nazi with Kelsey
Kelsey gr said no we get okay so he you
come down there and and who's laughing
at Who's down there I don't remember who
he was sitting with I think it was a
couple Comics or something I I don't
remember that's not a good that's not a
cool no it was not cool and and and
later he very sincerely and heartfelt
like he goes dude I'm really sorry you
know how we are in here we you guys all
trash each other I really thought it was
just like going to be this funny thing
it was not a good
move I'm really he and I go dude it's
totally fine what he could have just
done is tolde to give you a spot and had
everyone there and that way they he
still could have done the prank without
the hurting you anyway years later I I
passed and I still have the tattoo there
you go which tattoo is this and actually
I got it covered and redone not because
of that because I never was that crazy
about I okay I had I have the tattoo
here yeah KK k kick kicking them in the
nutes KK t n all right yeah cuz when I
met George Carlin he said keep he was my
idol said keep kicking them in the nuts
hell yeah thought it was awesome and I
saw an interview later where he said he
go they said Do you ever give advice to
Young Comics he goes I always tell them
to keep kicking them in the nuts I was
like oh he said that to me that's
awesome I like it and I got the letters
tattooed on my arm CU I was like what a
great reminder to sort of glance down at
your arm every time you feel like [__]
and go wow I was going to Slit and then
I saw the tattoo so I had it here but I
had it it looked it did look Aryan the
font I chose Mike Yard in fact at one
point was like what the [__] is that man
I was like oh this is this is bad I
[__] up I did this wrong so I got it
covered up and and redone here but the
joke part of what fueled gnome's joke
was meter kept like telling this story
actually Meer might have been there when
this happened Meer kept telling the
story to everybody of like and D Roa
thought that that like this was advice
just to him but he says it to and I go I
never thought that like
you're making up your verion of this so
it's funny for you to tell I was like
but I never there's like I I I knew what
it was right right that's and um and so
that was the that was the joke of to of
the tattoo to to for the prank that no
one played meker I was in the car and
and some of his it's like serious is
playing some of his old [__] came on and
man there were some Killers oh he was
the joke about uh the banking crisis and
he goes like I understand what they did
because like think about what you do in
Monopoly like you step over your own
Mother's throat you'll steal money from
her and that's a [__] game now think
about someone you don't care about like
that's a [__] brilliant wow a
observation did your's joke I'm I'm not
going to do it Justice's new joke about
uh trans trans goes he goes there's a
lot of debate about whether or not
people think trans women are actually
women and he's like uh I forget how he
sets it up it's he does something where
he goes he goes they I don't think they
are women I think they are actually
improved women he goes have you watched
them in sports it's not even
close damn oh man he's great so funny
such a great bit I love his bit about uh
like black dick is just a big part of
why you don't want to go to prison and
he's like black dick is now part of the
judicial system you know like I'm so
scared of black dicks getting in my ass
in the shower that I'm not going to
steal this candy bar you know the other
thing about going to I think it's part
of that bid where he's like uh how are
you're so scared to go to prison to get
raped he's like but there's people going
there who are like I can't wait to rape
people oh wow that's a take do you guys
want to I had it this bit never worked
was prison rape yeah I was like here's
the here's the weird thing about rape
the people in society that are most
terrified of rape are women obviously
uhhuh the safest place a woman could be
is prison she will never get raped in
prison wow unless it's a Transit mate
well but this is 10 years ago okay women
don't rape other women men are the
rapists then they go to jail and then
they get raped it's a startling irony to
me in all that I see what women must
there must be female rape in prison how
you a scissor how does that work well I
think uh women have sex with guards and
that's considered rape because this is a
power
Dynamic could you dude
could you imagine I I mean I don't mean
in a I mean in a consensual way yeah can
I can't think of anything hotter that if
I was a prison guard and a hot inmate
was like I want you to go [__] me like
in the showers right it's a porno plot I
would oh my God that is hot very hot hot
stuff and then you can just lock her up
after her you don't have to call you
sorry sorry lady sorry I didn't call but
you're in prison what you cuddle I I
have to do my job yeah yeah let me do my
job exactly um do you guys want to hear
what I believe is the most perfect joke
ever written right I assume it's not
yours oh okay come on lay it on me you
put these glasses on all
the it's a whole different
Mark uh it's Ron White yeah I think it's
a new joke I saw him telling it
skankfest
um I I told it to people last I was like
I think it's literally the most perfect
joke I've ever heard I always say he's
he's super underrated um here it is you
know how to tell the difference between
a rich kid and a poor kid it's how they
ask the question do you know who my
father is oh that is great that's that's
great it is it's perfect it took me a
second but it's perfect that's you don't
even have to finish it that's it that's
the joke I can hear it in his uh in his
delivery too you just picture him
delivering that's man he's great picture
him saying that sitting back taking a
sip and just letting it kill he's got
another one of mine he has a bit the
cheating in Columbus bit where it's like
uh he defends cheating he's like my wife
got that crazy idea in her head that I
cheated on her in Columbus and I didn't
I'll tell you why like just that he
opens a bit by being like I did it and
then the whole part of the bit was like
a woman was like uh you know uh let's uh
let's have a drink and he goes oh I
can't I'm married and she goes no come
come to my uh hotel room and have a
drink with me and he goes you know that
little fell that pops in shoulder and
reminds you of your past commitment and
your moral fortitude well I didn't hear
a peep out of
him that's a great [__] bit what a
great sense the fact that like you open
a bit pushing the audience Away by being
like I cheated and you know his crowd
probably a lot of married people and he
and then by the end they're [__]
dying that's funny he's a he's a great
he's I drunk in public album you put me
in public right before the uh right
before that set where I saw him tell
that joke I was talking to him backstage
a little bit at SC Fest I just went up
to him cuz I'd seen him the night before
in the green room and I was tanked when
I saw him and he's sober now yeah well
he's California sober weed well he does
he's done mushrooms oh
okay was just every other drug now yeah
well that's what everybody does they
quit booze then they they still like we
take I don't know if he still
does well this is evil that's why I mean
it kills your body cut this cut this
story okay well I hate you didn't even
say anything yet
he he wasn't D I don't think this oh I
see I don't think this is a secret oh
[__] it let's cut itut it cut it that's
a tough thing about podcast now you just
don't know but say what you will about
this cat but he's got one of the best
cheating jokes Pat Dixon he's his old
stuff was Unreal where he said uh a lot
of people say how the hell does cheating
happen well I'll tell you how it happens
a guy meets a woman and she's nice and
that's
it great all right I love that I love
those types of jok jokes where it's just
like they just end prematurely oh yeah
yeah know that's good stuff uh Dixon
used to have a joke where he said you
know you know it's going to be a good
[__] when she puts the Breathe Right
strip on her
nose that's
killer and he's like he's got that great
joke he's like women like when you send
flowers to work you know they can smell
them they smell great women love flowers
men I wish you could send [__] to work
you know they're they're they're pretty
and they
smell and that's
the minus great makes it a joke I agree
oh so you got Carlin saying kick him in
the nuts I did a set once where it was
like a little shaky I was killing and
then I went a little dark and I lost him
and Bill Burr was in the wings I didn't
know and he goes [__] this crowd keep
saying crazy [__] and then he went on
and that meant the world to then Mark
got a tattooed right here yeah pretty
cool yeah exactly yeah all right well
that's cool it's all the way down my leg
keep saying crazy [__] yeah all right
that's cool that's a nice moment you
need you need yeah when you're [__]
eating [__] as a young comic you need
just like anything because there no
there's no worst feeling having a bad
set and seeing a comic you [__] love
in the wings oh God I know I know I I'll
even see an open micer in the wings and
I'm like better bring the heat I got to
kick it up a notch bur changed my whole
trajectory oh yeah literally how
so with one set I was doing the old
Gotham uh
I remember at the time I had a bit about
I was very young and I had a bit about
um text me how much I hated text
messages and I was screaming about how
much I hate it probably in the T9 days
too yeah and uh I I uh I I killed I
killed so hard and and I was when I
first became friends with Bill and he he
came in we were going to go out drinking
and I looked up and I saw him like
watching as I was killing and I was like
oh yeah you you know and uh and I got
off stage and I'm waiting for the like
dude great job you know yeah and he goes
hey let me ask you a question do when
are you going to actually start talking
about what you're actually angry about
no you can be angry about text and I go
what do you mean and he goes you're not
that [__] mad about text messaging
wow and I go yeah but and he goes doosa
You Killed but I'm going to tell you
right now you don't want to become the
angry guy whoa that's fake start talking
about what really upset about and it was
hard to swallow in the moment and it
changed everything immediately I was
like okay and I was like you're right I
can't pretend to be mad yeah you know
but you are the angry guy like in real
life yeah but but also to uh it was it
was that and then Evan Steinberg my
first manager said to me he goes you're
not angry you're dejected there's a
difference that's a good way to put it
yeah and I was like so those two pieces
of advice really shaped like I was like
like yeah it's not about going up and
being like and let me cuz there's those
comics and I'll tell you another thing
that's [__] people you seen these
pull tabs on the no juice boxes you know
what I mean like the guy who's angry
about socks let me tell you about these
[__] ankle socks Jesus what sucks
ankles cold yeah you see this Prime
two-day delivery [__] you're
like but I was like you have to live you
have to always be that guy yeah yeah and
I was like oh yeah I don't want to be
that guy I want to be the guy that talks
about what actually does annoy me or
pisses me off and in the moment if I'm
talking about it and I start to get
worked up then I start to get worked up
that's real and if I don't then I don't
I can still talk about it it's but
that's like in acting like a lot there's
acting techniques where it's like you
don't go in going I am going to get
angry you go in saying this is what my
goal is and wherever the scene takes me
emotionally it could be anger or tears
or laughter or whatever and that's the
way I look at standup too my goal is to
get a certain reaction out of you and
I'm going to be emotionally present and
sometimes that reaction were where that
experience makes you get a little
aggravated sometimes it's jovial
sometimes it's a little more dead pan I
don't know like I don't think of you as
an angry person like I I feel like angry
people when I'm around them they drain
me and you're not you're not a draining
person irritated maybe yeah you're
definitely irritated I think it's
definitely a little but irritation is
funny to be in a constant state of
irritation is funny good point I think
it's I think it's definitely a little
it's it's more like in the Larry David
right zone of just like I can't let it
go everything is annoying you know what
I mean I do get too upset about certain
things but at the end of the day I'm not
a [__] what's the last thing you got
really pissed off about M
Hamas actually he didn't mind that um I
Heard a woman say I follow all these
women on YouTube that uh that tell you
what they think is hot about men I it
feels like everybody hates men so when a
woman's like this is what's sexy about
men I'm like all right finally but she
said when a guy gets angry that's hot
because it's like dominance and he he
tells you how he feels how about when
they're dejected is that hot dejected is
no good I think if you get the right
kind of angry in front of a woman like
takes like like I had a girl once with
me at the
bar and all this [__] was going wrong
and I was like and I and it was we were
kind of like on a date and I like had to
leave I had to leave her sitting
and I was walking back and and I'd kept
coming back and sitting with her and
then something else and I'd be like this
[__] never [__] ends Jesus [__]
Christ and I would get up again and I'd
come back and like I'm really sorry I'm
really sorry and are you [__] kidding
me right you know and then like after
she's like she's like I kind of thought
it was like hot there you go she like
you're like taking charge of [__] I like
oh that's cool exactly that's cuz you
own the bar an angry dude in the corner
would not be H well that would have make
sense yeah yeah that's true guys angry
what do you mean we're out of these
[__] glass I just bought these things
no you didn't you're just drinking here
what are you talking you're in control
that's why it's hot yeah that helps the
last thing this is the kind of [__] that
sets me off I was trying to book my Uber
here and uh I was getting nervous
because of traffic and I didn't want to
be late and I was trying
to like I pulled up the address and then
all of a sudden that red thing came up
at the top that's like sorry we can't
connect Network and I was like son of a
bit and then I backed out of the app and
then I went back in and then it wouldn't
like you know when it shows the address
but you're you're hitting it it's not
recognizing it and I go what the and
then the five star rating for my last
driver popped up oh and I just go
[__] get the [__] off the screen man
God damn it like like stuff like that'll
I'll make me crazy yeah know I'm with
you on that like Network because we're
so used to it now you know what annoyed
me recently and this is so stupid but it
bugs me that [__] Burger King ad that
jingle where they're like
BK have it your way you
rule that's such a pandering [__] ad
I hate pandering I know but it bugs me
you rule it's like they're trying too
hard that's not how you feel after you
eat Burger King true why don't you see
worth in yourself Sam thank you by the
way I just found out that push a te good
bartender
wrote I'm loving it get the [__] out of
here push the rapper wrote that whoa
that's not true I'll go pull it up
that's a great madeup fact though yeah
there's no no way he set for life if
that is true push T wrote the McDonald's
Infamous oh what D did you know that
Neil Young did you wrot did you know
that Neil Young wrote liberty liberty
liberty it's [__] that's a Neil Young
Jam uh wait a second wait a second yeah
go to the hold on a second you know that
R Kelly wrote eat
freshh oh boy there you go look at that
I got a drink with a the Pringle on the
what do you got here that's
a I'm digging this we're talking yeah
there we go whiskey it's a basically
like a apple fashion that's very good
dude uh I remember uh man all the
athletes they love like the Honey
whiskey and [__] you know I remember I
was in a in a bar Milwaukee in a [__]
Nick sweatshirt like many years ago and
they tell me Latrell spr well goes to
this bar every night and he's my
favorite player is a kid and I'm like
yeah he doesn't come here every night
he's there every [__] night and he
walks in and I'm like holy [__] spre
well so I'm like I'm a young dumb comic
I go up to him and I'm like ah Mr spre
well I'm a huge I'm a huge fan you know
and he's like okay uhoh and I was like
I'm scrambling in my head I'm like can I
get you a drink he goes I already got a
drink he's got his Apple whiskey or
whatever yeah Honey whiskey whatever and
I say uh well uh I'm like running out of
options and a way to connect and I just
panicked I was like I'm in the comedy
club next door and he goes I go it'd be
cool if you came to a show and he goes
don't count on it oh and I'm like oh my
God and then I I walk away I was like
that was brutal that's like a childhood
hero and then um another guy there with
us we didn't it was like a like a girl a
girl who's hosting's boyfriend was like
I'm going to I work for Bleach report
let me handle this he walks in and all I
see a spre well
going and I'm like well he got it worse
than me whatever thank God and then I
was like man that that was kind of a
bummer I do the shows for the weekend at
the end of the weekend the bartender was
like oh man I saw spree he wasn't too
friendly I was like he's like he's a
good guy he's just a little rough around
the edges and she goes I'm texting them
right now I said I was at the comedian
you met the other night's show and uh it
was actually a really good show and spr
spr writes back immediately yeah I met
him the other night great guy oh I got
the nice version wow but then I met him
years later like when I had the MSD show
and he was he was pretty friendly but I
was like man that was a [__] that's
when you just freeze with someone you
like no sadder moment was contract he
turned down 3 years 21 million when when
players weren't getting that [__] and
what was his reason he this was the it
was the quote that went viral he goes I
got to feed my kids and and so now
people like would yell that at him at so
it was bad you know cuz he never got a
contract after that he turned that down
and no other team offered him [__] and
he was still good it just wow but I
loved him dude he was my guy Jesus he
was a great player was whated choked his
coach what happened in Golden State he
no no he's retired but he in Golden
State he choked his coach cuz they they
got a disagreement PJ carisimo the
Knicks pick him up and it's one of the
things we were like this could be bad he
was awesome for us pull it up like
trying oh yeah he was the [__] man is
it choke on TV no it was in practice oh
it was in practice but he was a [__]
beast whoa I don't I've never even heard
the man's name until right now that's
him yeah he was a badass damn you're
lucky he didn't check you out I know I
don't know anything about uh anything
this is like for the way you love comic
books I love basketball okay I don't
well comic books not yeah but video
games video games horror movies okay all
right there we go see we can connect we
can connect there you go this is your
leather face I heard you I heard you
talking about the tales for the [__]
thing and I'm like I I get I get the
passion I got a second one did you yeah
remember when we cuz I was with you when
I won the auction for the first one and
I bought a second one that has my
favorite Tales from the CP story ever in
it and it was double what the first one
cost which issue uh that's a great
question it was like I think it's issue
number 32 and it contains a story called
counting cards Nar alert uh I'll know
the cover when you show it to me wow
look at this you ever see Bordello of
Blood with Dennis Miller terrible movie
it's that one with the elephant on the
cover yep uhoh
uh yeah it's a terrible movie but I I
like the Dennis Miller Parts yeah yeah
Dennis Miller is really funny in it I'm
a huge Dennis Miller fan I really wish
he would do do standup again I did his
show Once when he had he had he took
over Larry King's show on whatever I
don't know what network it was even on
but it was he took it over he was cool
as [__] yeah he's so [__] funny man
so quick I did a show two days before Co
it was like two days before the [__]
country shut down and I remember him
being like Oh yeah I got myself a little
covid drip like just kept making jokes
about it he's like he's like yeah give
me a break like anything's going to
happen I was like yeah the whole [__]
world shut down he's so funny he had
that line he goes uh Capri son that's
harder to get into than Martha Stewart
on some dirty
sheets my favorite Dennis Miller well
one of my favorite Dennis Miller he goes
uh he I got to try to remember the
wordings it's so good it's all about the
wordings he goes uh he goes he goes I
got into a cab in France the cab driver
smelled like he was getting a permanent
while eating
gargona in a meat processing
plant I go hey pal there's an extra
finsky in it if you run over a [__]
Skunk Man I mean it's like Jesus Christ
wow there's so many adjectives in that
gargona the skunk I mean doollo has a
little that I saw doollo hand a guy the
camera in the front goes get it get a a
few uh get a few shots of me and he goes
I took the camera home it was like I
gave it to Michael J fox shirtless in a
windstorm on a mechanical
bull how many yeah how many things could
you pepper in there keep getting funnier
Nick always finds the funniest word
choice it's like you know it'll be like
I saw homeless you know he the one about
the homeless guy sleeping and he goes
see he's you know I got an $800 mattress
at home this guy's sleeping like a baby
on a hinin bottle a broken H broken I
just sent you one Sal ause this this I
saw this like our buddy Mike Lawrence
co-wrote this on SNL this cracked me the
[__] up great writer Mike Lawrence dude
he's so funny I I didn't know M Mike was
writing for SNL he did it he did it when
uh Pete hosted because he I texted uh I
texted to Paulo the other day he had a
thing on Instagram one of his clips for
his podcast and he goes he goes so this
is a story about men that start
relationships according to the writer
Men Who start toxic don't don't put the
word toxic in there don't tell me what I
think [__] who who wrote
it or who wrote it I text him I go dude
I am losing my [__] at this [__] clip
and I just wrote in quotes [__] who
wrote it and he goes that's my favorite
line in
it uh remember I saw Nick once and he he
had a line in a Howard Stern roast years
ago where he goes yeah Howard comes from
a of a long line of a thick skinn Jews
you don't believe me I go to visit his
relatives in a lampshade Factory in oswi
oh and
to him and he goes that line came to me
like right outside the [__] like
Jesus Christ that came to you that's
hilarious the thing I sent you he was a
master of the of the roast stuff man he
was at it yeah he had oh man he had a
the roast jokes he did on like the Pam
Anderson roast were [__] insane oh
yeah he was ruthless he's like uh I
don't want to say Lisa Lampanelli [__]
a lot of black guys but they all call
her on her Sickle
Cell he had one he goes Pam Anderson
your movies are so bad if someone was
like you rather watch one of your films
or watch a baby seal Club to death I'd
be like call JLo and tell her a mittens
already a mittens come on the funniest
[__] L man oh man he was made for
those types of my favorite joke his of
all time it was he would do a one it was
a onew he did on a on a set he goes he
goes I was listening to some hip-hop
music today not by choice it was coming
out of a Jeep five blocks away from me
and then he goes speaking of music do
you guys see Jerry Garcia died they said
he was 55 I thought he was in his late
hundreds he's he's an angry guy he's a
oh no that's not what I sent you it's
coming up here oh yeah okay so wait what
what is this oh this is great you is
this kid yeah watch this is from the
Chris Rock Show though isn't it oh no
it's from uh SNL he's dressed like a
'90s
kid I thought this was from the old
Chris Ro what up
Harlem man you know when substitute try
to act like they're all that it's like
girl your
[Laughter]
big
ah well what is the premise
here first S no no no no there it was a
whole it was just the kids what I sent
you a different thing dude these guys
are funny that please don't destroy guys
wait a minute I think the original thing
though where he's the kid is from the
Chris Rock show is it yeah really yeah
and I think they took that and they're
doing a sketch about that on SNL no
because Lawrence told me he wrote one of
the lines in this it is a new thing yes
is it that's the
one yeah I've seen that's not what I
sent I've seen the one where it's just
the it's just like the trailer for the
show I know what you're talking about
yeah yeah it's [__] hilarious yeah
yeah yeah but it's not going back to
Pete it was just that huh well we'll
find it no I sent it to you oh I know
but it's not wow this gets this gets
awkward when Sam starts yelling at the
producers Jesus I never saw this side of
you Sam oh well let's him around
Christmas I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding you took that really seriously I
just joking s goes
sorry it's the holidays I'm trying to be
nice here yeah well sorry Salomon look
at this guy he's mans spreading on the
couch he's mansplaining to you the is
man toxic toxic male guest coming what
happened with them he said he's going to
be here at 245 oh right the other is
that or is that the surprise no no we
got Dennis Miller coming oh no I wait so
what's the big surprise yeah you
surprise it's not the guest it's did you
just say surprise just to make me think
there was a surprise
possibly that's a surprise I really got
excit I would be here either way but I
really got excited like there was like a
surprise happen I love surprises oh
really oh yeah yeah you don't not not a
lot of people like surprises I hate
surprises I don't understand when people
say I I mean if it's a movie I don't
want spoilers I want to be surprised if
it's it's like a but like when
somebody's like do not throw a surprise
party for me I tell my wife every year I
hate I'm like what who who would hate
that well what if you're in a weird mood
and then all of a sudden you're like oh
I got to Chum it up with L Linda from
work go sit in the corner and drink till
you're having a good time got an option
okay here it is here we go what is this
now same one but this just your big ass
down and put on
a oh [__] original prin of they might be
small but they got big
featuring smoke do Marsh oh smoke do you
don't
take yeah [__] I
got piano
Rec Ah that's
great you know when you you can't get
your straw in the front of apri Sun so
you got to like hit it from the
back that's
funny the the names are the funniest of
the
kids he that
right happens what I do with all this
ass it's funny cuz there are adult
Comics who do crowd work like this yeah
but here's why again again uh not to
challenge you Sam because I see how you
can get don't challenge me but again
this is not like it's
it's that's like a direct joke about
Kings of Comedy like why would SNL and
then the kid grown up in the sketch tur
into Pete looks like that kid grow up I
didn't know I didn't know it was in that
context I only saw it like this I think
this was a older sketch on something and
now they're reusing it cuz look the
kid's grown up when it gets to the
office with Pete it's the same kid no
it's not please don't destroy guys no no
no look the redhead that's not him no he
goes That's my first set that's that's a
joke joke and I think they hired kids to
do that I don't know I think it's it's
not him dude am I crazy crazy all right
you know those please don't destroy guys
they're [__] hilarious who's the no
who the hell those three kids right
there they just made a movie on peacock
I heard it's funny do you see
it those were the kids from SNL that
just made a movie yeah yeah okay geez
man you got to get out of that bar
you're living under a
rock what do I care what some guy does
on peacock good point good point the
angry guy about
peacock see there's a new [__]
streamer I got to sign up for now it was
called NBC when I was a banging you see
this peacock [__] I'll tell you call
it PE [__] folks then maybe I'll watch
it now let me ask you this speaking of
[__] have you covered the trans lady
hand job enough yet by the way I found
out you hooked up with a trans person
cuz someone heckled me with it while I
was on stage in Phoenix same I was just
I was just on stage and someone goes
what do you think about D Roa and the
trans chicken I was like I don't I love
that my name's coming up at your show
yeah mine too oh it's great I was like I
was like I yeah yeah she's a she's a
friend and and she's great Nikki Fox and
uh well we talked about it a ton man I
mean I don't care I'll talk about it but
like you and I talked about it on
Bobby's thing the day after it happened
but have you got another one since cuz I
know you were really excited have I
hooked up with another trans woman since
no I haven't but you know well there's a
surprise come on out
Shirley no I'm just kidding what once
again you got me very excited what God
damn it is do you prefer trans women or
are you uh or what what's I Haven I
haven't been with enough trans women to
say I could prefer a a ciswoman versus a
trans woman I don't think I don't think
it's a preference I just it's you know I
think uh you know Leah Thomas is she on
your wall who's Leah Thomas the swimmer
oh I don't know who that LE oh I was
thinking of Leah Thomson from Back to
the Future
Bo bring her up [__] film knowledge
yeah right uh I'm not I don't find Leah
attractive all right that's
offensive that's okay oh there's Sam and
and uh Joe's X where on the right
Sam it's Michael
Phelps um I yeah I don't know I don't
think there's a preference or anything
like that I think it's just you know
people are people here here but the the
giant dong would throw me off uh a a
dick with a woman for some reason is is
arousing to me wow a dick a dick on a
man I couldn't care less I I'm not
attracted to men it's the femin Discover
this there no no I I I knew I knew
before that I had an attraction I had
hooked up with uh a transom when I years
and years ago in Amsterdam oh uh just a
by chance thing um and so so I I I knew
that like I had an attraction but like I
just hadn't been really presented with
with uh too many opportunities I guess
to pursue it um and you know it's just I
don't know I never really thought of it
I swear to God too I'm not trying to
sound like Mr Progressive Enlightenment
or whatever I just never thought of it
as like well that's a trans I'm hooking
up with a transwoman versus I'm hooking
up with a straight I'm just like I'm
just living life and and you encounter
who you encounter and and if you're
attracted to them and something happens
great so yeah did you feel were you ever
insecure about ever like oh I feel weird
that this is maybe not you know the norm
or widely accepted yet no
I I I got a real attitude with people
that are going to take issue with me uh
with anything I had one person in my
life really questioned me and and I was
like and I said if because they had said
that their friends were kind of giving
them some [__] about it and I was like
if your [__] friends or you or
anybody has a problem with it I go [__]
yourselves like I you know everybody's a
[__] liberal till it's time to be a
liberal you know everybody's a liberal
till it's time to be a liberal you hear
that Hunter Biden you know so so that's
that and and and and she was this person
I'm talking about was fine with it yeah
yeah but that's kind of douy to be like
I'm fine with it but right that's kind
of I'm not saying it's not and and I
want to just out of respect for her say
she didn't necessarily presented that
way but I did have a very strong
reaction to it like because I'm very
like you know I I'm I'm the type of guy
if I'm bombing I'm yelling at the
audience and telling them that they
[__] suck like it's like I'm not a
guy that's going to go so so if my
family ever found out um and and and
they might know I don't know it's not a
thing where I'm I don't feel any need to
do anything yeah so if they find out and
have an issue with it I would be like
well all right I guess we're done here
I'm not a guy that would be like but
it's my yeah yeah the only person I know
who's upset about is
Norton he yeah he did it
first that's that'd be great if people
were like they were like you stole their
bit but it's just their personal
life yeah right I [__] started that
dude oh
[Applause]
[__] there we go you might SL yeah there
we go hey hey
right here Matt here I wonder why he's
late I wonder what took him so long what
was the hold up I talked to Keith this
morning you were the first person I
talked to today no way I talked to Keith
many mornings in the week you guys are
still tight right very that Mike very
very very I don't
like and uh we're very tight we should
say out of the gate Keith is recording a
special uh December 19th at Sony Hall if
you don't get tickets get him now his
new hours [__] awesome killer so
funny oh man what you what are you going
to do with positivity Keith you don't
know how to handle it we'll get it out
way
early what's up a it's like my dick what
the [__] is this was a fine
[Laughter]
ass well I gotta say Keith you did that
that whole bit with the guy with the
cane and I was like that's a that's
that's a clip and it's up there now on
Instagram ah goddamn right we had to
annoy Liz to get it though he won't
Keith won't play the game no I'm never
going to play the game what's the game I
don't know just post game
is Joe just bugs
me good I don't want you in my life
anything to repel you is
good you are such a [__] [__] yes
I call I can call Keith any day of the
week and go I want to trash this person
and he's like yeah I know it makes me
sick so we called Voss this morning a
Vos cuz we're tired of
vos's vos's pro Israel protesting on
instam it's infuriating his boss could
be the dumbest man I've ever known and
him acting like he's about to call I
called ke I go I I can't handle this
anymore Keith's like I got [__] [__]
sucker we call the V off and Keith goes
you're making me hate
[Laughter]
Jews dude I saw a clip I saw a clip of
lo I saw a clip of loss recently made me
laugh out loud where he's like he call
first off he's like in his 60s and he
calls a woman in the front row he goes
Miss you're a [__]
two what man in their 60s so I remember
I did a bringer show when I was like a
brand new comic and Voss was on the
lineup and my it's like the first time
my mom came to see me oh and V in the
crowd and he said to woman in the crowd
she goes miss you were two on a Tuesday
and after the show my mom goes that man
was
[Applause]
repulsive I [__] love Voss oh he's
just the fact that he's he's still
pumping up those he said something about
like I I would step over [__] Freddy
Mercury's or for your body to suck
Freddy Mercury's dick thre him in the
crowd I'm like Jesus Christ we need a
compilation of those wouldn't that be
great
bestu is a pain in ass best I have I
have the greatest Keith Robinson Story
of all time there we go please I've told
this on many podcasts I've never told
front of you I don't think I can't wait
this is the greatest Keith Rob it's
great so couple years
back uh my aunt passed away right we
were really close and she passed away I
was very sad so I was down in Jersey
with my family trying to help you know
with everything and it sucked and Keith
for whatever reason was calling me like
every day cuz he wanted to talk to me
about something I don't remember what it
was and I wasn't answering and I also
wasn't calling him back cuz I was
dealing with my dead aunt and it was a
horrible time sure horrible that Clos
with the aunt very close second mother
so got it we're in and it was also the
the like fifth person in many deaths in
my family in a short period it was a
very bad time yeah so anyway I'm
driving I'm driving my hand to God I'm
driving from the funeral mass to the
cemetery to bury her okay I'm in the
funeral procession
my you know and you drive like 10 miles
an hour things and my phone rings and
it's Keith again and I'm like this what
the [__] with this [__] guy so
finally I answer I go yeah
hello and he goes listen to me you
[__] [__] when I call you you
call me the [__] back you take my calls
you piece of [__] what the [__] you got
going on that you can't take my [__]
calls you got nothing happening right
and I go well Keith if you need to know
uh my aunt died so I've been dealing
with that for the last few days I'm
driving to bury her right now okay
that's why I called you back okay there
just a long pause he just
goes yeah Ann always bug
me ah you never met her
that's that's why it's funny I mean just
a piece of
[__] I'm a good dude man yeah good guy
it's funny it's a drinking podcast but
you sound the drunkest that's we you
know my stroke oh right
God damn it you have a joke in the in
the new hour where you you talk about
taking a Viagra on Thanksgiving uh on a
flight to Phoenix to get ass and that's
what caused a stroke that's what caused
a stroke man is that what did it yeah
that was don't fly and pop our Vagas
really why like why like what what's the
effect that happens pressure they were
going on the scent okay and I you know
when the PA make the announcement you
know I'm like oh [__] I'm going take a v
so I can be ready
when and I po that boy and then was and
then this oh [__] my voice St g wow as I
was walking what but you were walking
you started slurring and [__] you're
like oh here we go I had to get the
[__]
first you didn't make it to the [__] oh
absolutely oh you did what you think I
was going straight to the
hospital a [__] [__] this is the
second time you did not go straight to
the hospital this is a second Str second
one damn I'm a
man that's incredible I hope she
appreciated it
no tough guys plop uh blue pills there
you go when you're tough you take it and
you keep going now you know what every
man in here should have done something
to put that life at Rin for ass I
respect oh yeah I've done that there
that's right I followed a girl on a
bicycle in
China through the woods cuz she was like
I sounds like her life was at risk no
she goes women women you want women I
was like yes and I followed her through
the woods on a b I'm luy I didn't get
murdered like after the fact I was like
what the [__] was I
doing I want to um like uh know out on
housing project uh for this girl like 2:
in the morning now when out on housing
projects it's 98% chance of getting
robbed
killed or you know beat real bad right
but that 2% that I get laid was good
enough damn I want did you get the did
you get laid no I I had up running
out you know that project is name but we
do every man should have a
story of about to get killed for Dawn
yeah you got to roll the dice at least
once yeah yeah yeah that's all you have
I mean the amount of bars I went into
Mexico drunk going are there [__] here
you know and just getting chased out he
took a shot yeah oh yeah I've done some
stupid [__] man Jesus chist the amount
of drinking and driving alone I've done
to chase some
clam it's some bananas but you know
what's cool about cops sometimes get
pulled over and I'm like I'm going to
meet a girl I'm so horny and he's like
get out of here keep going they get it
then a black guy tells him the same
story he's like get out of that car you
piece of [__] that's funny as hell I'm
trying to get laid man all right go
ahead go yeah that should be a breath
lizer for [__] like I just ate out a
girl all right all right I smell it yeah
how horny you are yes it's a horny
bizer 2.8 and a guy yeah that that
actually it's true you should get if you
you can blow [__] and leizer that's you
that should get you off cuz they know
you're on your way home yes exactly what
was I going to do stay I just met this
chick I had to get home [__] hammered
I don't know where the [__] she lives
good point I'm sorry about the
schoolyard I'm going straight
home school's out of session I sure I
drove to the D [__] on the road dude the
girls that when I was a younger comic
that I went back to places with oh yeah
did I went to a I went to a trailer once
did coke with some chick to like 5 a.m.
there was a bunch of dudes that were
just there and they ended up being cool
but it's like that's the weirdest what
the [__] man like it's it's like dumb
like it's like you did meth No Coke oh
coke meth well I don't know trailer no
meth is a drug I don't I know but Coke
sounds expensive for a trailer their
life is not well that was dumb too she's
just like I have Coke do you want to do
it I was like yeah sure like it's just
stupid dude yeah is this a holiday
edition yeah yeah now we just dressed
like this on a Tuesday cuz I just got
out of my stupid Uber and he's playing
Christmas music the whole [__] time
cuz it's Christmas time [__] not
right now when when do you want to start
playing the music it was it was really
annoying what song was it Have a Holly
Jolly
like it's Christmas time it's December
it's December 8th or whatever 8th I mean
well when Keith took a Viagra his heart
grew three times inside
ohh yeah driving a [__] sorry still
reminiscing I'm married so I got to
think sometimes I'll lay in bed at night
and I can't sleep and I'll just think of
all the
vagina dad like Su
plums remember that girl remember that
time yeah there just being we went to
Brazil everybody know about that story
you Patrice n thanks to Kevin brenon we
all know about oh yeah who is you
Patrice nordon who else Norton um Robert
Kelly oo baby and you know we that's a
that's a hard of danger right and that
in Brazil now that that was insane to me
that you guys would go down there and
then just the the the chances of AIDS
and
everything take take all the disease
parts off the table what Aid I did my
bit my my Di has been on so many tours
of
Duty you know it serve well be and
Yannis being and Yannis down sorry be
and ynis Pap used to call each other cuz
all the pamphlets say 2 to 22 days for
any VD 2 to 22 days 2 to 22 days so we
would we would always laugh when we call
each other and go W dude I'm on a 2 to
22 right now you know so jannis started
going I call him and I go hey dude and
he goes oh [__] what you doing a bid you
doing a bid right now I'm like I'm doing
a bid and then fin I start to call him I
go I go bro I don't know how to live on
the outside
anymore I stay I stay locked up at this
point dude you ever get any um
STDs no clap no gun nothing what none
yet wow yet I mean I don't know what I
don't know what the future holds but no
not yet I got four chenas four yeah four
wow we talking this calendar year no no
way back how fast after you banged did
the chyia kick in oh you wait are you
waiting right
now I might be on a stint right now oh
boy no seriously though I'm just curious
cuz I never I never never happened like
well you get that burn when he when you
pee and a burn but what I'm saying how
long after though would it kick in I can
kick in two days one day do you have
when you get it do does it hit you
immediately like it was this girl I know
who did it like I was doing so much me
and my
girlfriend I think she had it from
somebody else oh and I so we didn't know
we just looked at each other like all
right whatever wow cuz she could have
gave it to me I could a gave with her
it's like an STD Mr and Mrs Smith yeah
who done
it that's great so wait you had four for
is camia the clap or goria the clap
chyia four four claps four G it sounds
like a Christmas carol for
claar one
HPV gnie or
clap I think
goria cuz sometimes it takes a while is
goria painful yes I've never had that
one I heard there's a discharge yeah
nice little sounds gross P shooting out
oh I was shaving with it it was so much
coming
out
have you had have you gotten burned HPV
but it was I had an outbreak but it's
gone I mean you can get it Zapped off
but yeah years ago oh damn the but
that's not
really everyone is HPV I streets we
don't count that as thank you that's
some you know [__] yeah the only one
I ever had was the um it's like the wart
I think we talked about this on on
Tuesdays the wart thing it's not HPV but
there's like a there's like a wart thing
that you get like kids get it a lot and
then you can get it just from contact
but it's it's not even counted as an
like f mesum or something I got that
count hold up that sounds like an excuse
you give a girl now everybody gets it
you you know no I'm I would I would be
honest I would be honest but I'm dead
serious the the doctor that treated it
said she said this isn't even
categorized where you have to tell
somebody about it it's like a fungus
he's a cool doctor it a chick it was a
chick doctor so all right she you know
it's a check so it's got to be okay I
hate women doctors they get so
preachy in Philadelphia had the free
clinic so when you want in there you
know and they have certain
sections like for
SV yeah and some for like you know other
regular [__] right I tried to S the
regular [__] one I said what do you got
sir um I said get your ass over here you
know
go the quarter with the rest of the
degenerates mesum is is not I mean I got
that from a [__] towel I was living
in Phil that's what she was saying she
was like this could be from a lot of
different things what what was that you
it's called like I think F molescum it's
like a nothing it's a whatever did your
girlfriend buy that when you told her
that you get it that's what I'm saying
it was
a you got to get it burnt off but but
like they that's why they were saying
they were saying it's common amongst
kids a lot because it's so transmittable
and they're like you can get this from
anything it's not an STD like or or you
might have gotten it from sex but we
it's that's a that's a [__] disease I
that's what I'm saying I never had any
real hardcore you know you should have
wood again Christ Plankton from water
column Jesus Christ yeah though this the
craziest is I thought I had AIDS you
know your brain just goes crazy places
when you got something going on downtown
and I went to the doctor I was like I
got AIDS I know it and he goes are you
gay and I go no and he goes do you use
needles and I go no and he goes you're
fine that was a medical professional
told me that wow Magic Johnson's doctor
said the same thing didn't you get that
crazy you had something [__] up H
pylori I had H pylori you get that from
eating ass so watch out there Keith this
sounds disgusting come on know you know
how much ass hate listen to this what he
got from it this this almost SC I'm a
man I told you that's not a
mustache that's FAL matter why you think
I can't talk now
[Laughter]
that's from EA ass that's not from
Viagra how does Viagra how does Viagra
give you a stroke is it high blood
pressure I guess being on the
airplane cuz they recommend that you
don't take it while on the plane I
didn't read that before I didn't know
that either yeah and by the way taking
it to get ready you got the Uber ride
you had you had a lot of time to take no
when pal made announced 20 minutes left
in flight 10 minutes the girl's house
total of 30
minutes that's how long it take for I
have a bag where to kick in so you
didn't think that from the moment you
stepped off the
plane it would be possibly a full 30
minutes before you were inside of
stopped out the plane I got you know got
off the plane went to the Uber Uber
there was 10 minutes to a house I know
I'm saying you don't walk in and
immediately ins want to knock on our
door with my
dick
nice and
all
I all right I guess so I don't know I
thought maybe you have a glass of water
or something
no the seller like every night it's make
it does make me feel guilty as hell when
I cancel with a hangover and he's
[__] walking in like
this right now Keith makes me feel like
I don't work hard enough well we should
make you feel that way too no you guys
are
stupid this guy just doesn't want to be
home
what are we talking about here guilty
true not wrong um no Keith I actually I
was saying this to Dante the other Dante
near the other day I was like Keith's
resolve is is truly inspiring like you
you you you oh man I'm going to
cry good that's what I wanted you know
this guy bugged me right there oh that
yeah yeah yeah it just Bugg me I don't
know what it is is it the
face he reminds me of me fin I could see
it I'll take it you don't you don't like
Ian and
I okay fair enough looks like Ron Jeremy
after
prison they show those cord photos of
him and they're like he's got dementia
[Laughter]
now all right I go with that Ron Jeremy
now I like him I like you now hey you're
back all it took you've been initiated I
guess you don't want a
cocktail no pressure
a sweet wine do you have any wine we can
do that no problem Oh not a sweet wine
but a wine a good wine red a swirl as
Keith calls it nice can I do another you
guys having a second I'll do another
yeah yeah should we do another rum you I
want to try the Apple thing too I could
I have a like whiskey not sweet though
just like a straight up and down you
know maybe a little something in it but
nothing give him a bodega cat on the
Rocks guys Bodega cat whiskey.com
bodat yes yes it is I don't I'm not
you're not
a yeah yeah yeah I like Bodega cat but
I'm not a r I won't be able to drink it
thank you thank you no I I I wanted to
ask more about that um H pylori yeah
yeah well I was this is a [__] horror
what an effect crazy crazy effects uh
you get it from eating ass it's feal
matter you ingest I was [__] in water my
tongue was sheet white I had a distended
belly like a like those African theal
yeah and I couldn't get it up I was
peeing foam I had all kind of stuff just
felt horrible I was tired all day aw
yeah I was puffy I got bloated pull up a
picture of me at my Comedy Central
presents that was a I thought
you we're all adults now it's time to
ditch the old paper posters you have
hanging on the walls with Scotch tape
keep your fun sense of style but level
things up with displate dis plates are
solid metal posters you can install on
just a few seconds they come with a
magnet that you stick to the wall and
then displate sticks to the magnet
insanely simple uh I mean they have all
these great kinds too right you've seen
this like they' like back to school and
stuff great movies all these old Mo
vertigo and uh all these old cool
Hitchcock I got taxi driver do you have
that one I do yeah that's sick it's a
beauty right in front of the taxi very
New York dark gritty I use that as a
tour poster it's a great poster oh yeah
that's right with such easy with such an
easy mounting system you can switch your
disc plates out whenever you feel like
changing up your artwork to some tons of
officially licensed design some popular
movies like we said Star Wars Marvel
stranger things check out their cool
Landscapes uh man cave designs and even
maps of your favorite cities whatever
you're into display it has a metal
poster to show it off save up to 30% off
when you click the link in the shows
notes discount will be automatically
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use the code drunk when you
visit display.com that's display.com
code drunk or click the link in our show
notes oh yeah hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by Aura the holidays are
all about connecting with loved ones and
there's no better way to do that than
with a digital picture frame from Aura
wire cutter called it the best digital
photo frame and it's easy to see why you
can upload your favorite pcks of the
family to one frame and relive all those
happy moments again or share big news
like a new addition of the family love
AA I mean who wants one photo that what
do we Amish come on mix it up get a
screen in there show the whole ski trip
and the the family and the kids and if
that's not your per if that's not
personal enough you can even upload a
video message to play on the frame as
soon as they plug it in that's brilliant
this holiday season listeners can save
on the perfect gift by visiting Aura
frames.com drunk that's a frames.com
drunk use promo code drunk and get 30
bucks off the bestselling frames get on
it happy holidays great frames I I have
two of them in my apartment they're
killer there you go man what do we speak
ass get in here so you got to scoot over
let me ask you hey
Marina here do you recognize it's a
Christmas miracle Marina can we can we
get you a
cocktail no pressure no pressure yeah
hello I mean I don't drink but what kind
of oh my god look how bloated are that's
how fat I was sorry we're in the middle
of STD talk Mark Mark got a h pylori
from eating butt and that's look what a
dis face look how big I got that's all
just fat and like swollenness so did you
did you stop
no by the way yeah are I had to shoot
while while all [__] up but hey Marina
good to see you thanks for coming oh
that's good Mark didn't you say Mark
didn't you say you peed foam yes what
yeah cuz it's it's a virus it just goes
all through you and I was like I have
AIDS do you know which girl did it yeah
yeah you call her no well what's not her
fault she her [__] got in his mouth oh
yeah I was the one with the
spoon so I guess it's not like an STD
STD you you just got it from eating poop
yeah and it was back when I was hot so I
was trying it out and I just got out of
like 11-year relationship so I was going
hard when I when I got HPV I remember
thinking uh like a girl popped into my
head cuz she was too easy and you're
like well she was willing I remember I
was in St Louis and she dm' me after the
shows like many many years ago and she
goes can I uh can I come to your room
and I was like sure I saw the picture
she look good and I was like a girl that
was that agreeable I was like it's her
yeah probably Missouri and that easy
that's a recipe for [__] disaster
what do you think Marina you're a lady
just thinking I never get laid in
Missouri really or I after show and
stuff like that there's never been an
this was young hungry Sam on the RO an
easy guy I never get easy lays really no
and I've never HPV I don't have it never
given it out you want it you don't know
that by the way what do you mean you
don't know if you have it no I have
really I check I get checked all the
time I think you only know you you go to
the papsmear no they can they can check
women for it they can't check men for it
gives you can cervical cancer yeah
I didn't know you knew that yeah no it's
I feel bad for women cuz it's like men
men carry it all the time and don't know
they have it they come on I don't feel
bad for women I'm not surprised I'm not
surprised I'm not surprised why is your
jacket not warm enough it's 32° outside
what why is your jacket not warm enough
it's 32 degrees I got a car get my car
and you know but you took it Uber yeah I
got a car though oh you got a car all
right so what do you do for the 43
minutes it takes you to walk from the
front door the to the Uber you're going
to get sick you are such an
[__] he he's mess with the
handicap how do you feel good
great you got to easy out every time oh
that's not a red wine red wi that looks
like apple juice orange wine that's oh
orange wine it's pretty good actually
let me Telly I'll try this I've had that
before it's not bad is that Natty [__]
it's natural not it's natural wine yeah
all right it's good stuff gra o thoughts
love it hate it Marina would like a
drink too beer Jew that's possible you
drink whiskey no I don't drink but
uh a little club soda with maybe like a
[__] have you never drank what I
can't have a club soda I have club soda
was like maybe like a lemon absolutely
thank you she smoked weed I smoke a ton
of weed yes but I don't drink I stopped
drinking years ago cuz it wasn't helping
my workout regimen uhuh if I like weed
I'd quit drinking yeah same it's a shame
I don't like weed I don't like it I feel
like it's better for you for sure way
better it's definitely better it helps
me sleep it it calms me down from my
attacks CU you who's got their own
liquor
you yeah yeah they do Bodega cat whiskey
available
online whiskey.com yeah grab it in there
are you guys able to sell this in New
York yet nope we're still working on it
and if anyone can help with distribution
we got meetings coming up but Mark and I
are pretty incompetent inel ask us
questions and we're like we don't know
what those words mean we had a guy from
the from the from Dallas really big time
us that was embarrassing like you guys
don't know anything no I would love to
do a big Cat event at the bar but we're
not allowed to cuz you can't yeah oh
who's going to know you got blow all
over the
place blow come every yeah they're not
going to wor you're fine uh listen if
you guys want to do it I I would love to
do it but I don't know what the rules
are for distributed
whiskey cures what you had there you go
after you there you go eat a good ass
yeah and then it is a cure all it's good
for what ails you but I had to go to a
doctor and get a a shot where'd he put
the shot he just shot me in the ass but
uh once I got the shot it was like
cleared up in one second really yeah H
pylori so you may just take a menad
drill I tried all that it was
Stronger this is poo we talking going
say that seriously Keith is not a good
doctor a benad dril you got AIDS take a
benad dril I take benad dril all the
time just to sleep it helps just said
knock myself out it knocks you out bad
Yeah I broke out with some [__] and they
gave me a benol well that's for allergy
or something no vadil is for allergies
yes no I ate some [__] some
food and um crab I ra crab cake and my
face is all swollen and yeah that's an
allergic reaction allergic reaction no
but I'm saying he may had an allergic
reaction to ask to
[__] I think we all do you're not
supposed to eat [__] no which is weird
cuz it's just from food you know how did
they get from good food to poison this
is like edgy
Seinfeld what's the deal with feces it
goes in one way that is that is a good
point though that it it's is weird how
it yeah that it's that dangerous yeah
it's just waste well it's waste but it
came from food that I that someone ate
it's fascinating it's transitioned into
something nasty and deadly ah you wa
some trans poop yeah I guess so all
right poop is trans dude thank you
Caitlyn [__] all right I couldn't
find the joke look at that that's a nice
drink oh thank you beard je are you sure
where do you B usually all over the
place well let me know if you're looking
for some shifts we're hiring all right
to Keith special December 19 Sony H
go the key special tiet for that it's
going to be a banger I'm thinking about
special needs is the title cuz special
special needs but yours is pretty good
too I like I do like that thank you
what's the title Different
Strokes come on that was right there for
everybody that's good you got to go with
that had two strokes man that's crazy
you had two man two is wild that's a
good title that's a really good title
good yeah two of them yeah is has there
been a stroke special you might be the
Jackie Robinson of Strokes the way Ellie
Wong went Ellie Wong went pregnant he's
going to start the stroke thing yeah
right yeah Josh Blue is like why didn't
I think of
that hey you know I got like handicapped
Comics looking at me
like like competition yeah that's
hilarious well simbad may be like oh he
took all my material
is he okay he's like has to like learn
how to like walk and [__] it sucks oh no
funny as hell man [__] beast it's sad
man he looked like he was in decent
shape too like it's like [__] up like
happens to people you can't look at a
person and say ah he's never G to have a
stroke oh yeah Jamie
Fox that's right he was ripped yeah so
Keith you're ahead of all I was RI too
yeah Jamie Fox stop stealing Keith's act
okay so wa that's what happened to Jamie
had a f a stroke they finally came out
and said is he is he okay now that's not
seems okay they haven't said it yet they
haven't said anything emergency is what
he said he's he was crying recently
though this week about how he wouldn't
want this to happen to anyone might
might be the most talented Entertainer
period like just think of all the [__]
he can do he's like you know I say it's
Eddie Murphy yeah but he can't sing yeah
he can Eddie can sing David Allen grer
is also up
there underrated I think as far as that
list goes as [__] he had hit singles
in the Eddie it kills me it kills me
with Eddie
Murphy he's so talented I hate that he
keeps doing these movies that I'm like
come on dude like this Christmas movie
that's out it's like he wants to he
wants to be Disney he's got kids he got
kid this guy could my friend put it so
well the other day he goes he goes this
guy could literally do any he could do
action he could do drama he could and he
keeps doing these like not even good
family and he has a little smile on his
face like he
knows I'm not giving it to you he does
and then he goes on Kimmel and he's
hilarious he's like doing the interview
and I'm like he's so funny still I
thought I thought with the Dolomite
movie I was like he's all right he's
back we're going to get [__] Eddie
again and it was a fun movie too yeah
and it was funny it was great and then
and then it's just like he's just I
don't know I will say I agree with you
but I don't think you should do standup
that I would stop I uh I think he he'll
be funny and see he was young when he
first did it yeah he like 18 it's crazy
you know 21 when he did Delirious wow he
says it in special 21 or 22 that's
insane he's like 28 when they did um raw
yeah wow I don't even think he was 28
dude I don't think what I'm saying is
that young yeah he has a lot more in him
but is he willing to go out and bomb and
work it out and that's the problem he's
so famous can that guy work out anywhere
I don't think so he said that's one of
the reasons when he was hesitant to do
it again he said because you can't truly
work out because you got to worry that
somebody's going to tape it and then
you're going to get in trouble and
whatever you know what rich rich famous
people do do like in the Hamptons they
have their little like shindy parties in
their homes and stuff he could do
something like that cuz I ended up in
one of those now he's got to come to
place to work out though it's not but
it's like the only situation he could
put himself in is like a like a house
party where it's like all let him go to
Grizzly
pair with the with the whatever that's
called with the bags the phone bags
Yonder he could just do that that's true
I that's what Chappelle does Chappelle
yeah if The Comedy Store did that I me
the seller does that yeah but would they
give him a honest reaction CU they're
like Eddie Murphy he can say anything I
think after the first few minutes yeah
first few minutes then God this gu
stinks right oh he's good they did that
to Robin Williams when he came to the
seller really they gave him the first
like and then you could see Robin was
like oh I got to work whoa I actually
saw that trans that Circle in his head
right you need to lock up his phone when
he's around he oh that's what I've heard
also he's dead now guy who's taking shot
at a dead comedian yeah I was going to
say not when Eddie gets up when Eddie
does [__] in front of a live AUD like at
his Mark Twain thing hilarious and again
like he's just paneling on Kimmel he's
just riffing and I'm like he could he
could do he could 1,00% do stand great
absolutely on Seinfeld he was funny you
know on the on the Comedians and Cars oh
yeah he still has like all the same
mechanisms that he had he said something
out of the W show that had me rolling
about the syney Fortier he said like he
had his hair was oh
yeah comb right he didn't comb his hair
they didn't have black makeup artist
back then so they didn't know how to do
his hair so it's all [__] up but it
was hilarious cuz he never had his hair
combed any movie whatever the Sydney 4's
here was just that was hysterical to
notice that that's very fun that's very
funny so he could do it but I don't
think he loves comedy oh you think the
same thing goes for Steve Martin because
I think he's another dude that could be
a hilarious he does Steve Martin does
still kind of do it though like when
they do when he does the stuff with
Martin Short Steve Martin still does
like like his whatever his new whatever
his current version of standup is he
will do it um yes you know when he
hosted the Oscars he did it like I was
thing Eddie was going to host the Oscars
and I was like okay we're going to get
and he didn't do it I think he I think
those first two specials are held in
such high regard that for who for just
every 48y olds I mean the young people
don't know him and what do you think
about the amount of [__] he dropped
including him getting caught with the
Trans woman caught with I would that
would be my opening 10 minutes you ever
heard my old [__] this is how it starts
you can't talk like that anymore and I
would just do a whole [__] thing but
dude the guy the guy's a a global brand
at this point I think in his head he's
like I did two specials they're Classics
I'm not going to [__] they're
Classics to me to you but I'm saying to
the said they were I'm the judge he does
that he'll go back and forth with his he
didn't do stand up on SNL when he hosted
SNL he didn't do stand up in the model
no he did but he was doing jokes no he
didn't he had every black cast member
come out and he does have that little he
does that little smile like I know that
was on the Mark Twain thing oh nobody
mentions Murphy's special when they go
to top special yes they do I think know
this is godamn itth this going be one
they always talk
about raw especially they always talk
about raw everyone talks about I mean my
relationship was broken up by raw but
that's why was it broken up by raw why I
was in high school and we went to the
movie theater to see it who and I could
see again the wheels turning and as he
was listening to him talk about women I
saw my boyfriend going yeah I don't have
to be with
you and um we he after that he started
dating other cuz I wasn't giving it up I
was a virgin I was like my yeah that I
was like in high school I was like in a
V Club that's
pointless I was very serious virgin back
then I was like trying like I was trying
to be a good family girl my grandfather
always sounds like a horrible dating for
a by the way I'm a very serious Legion
yeah I got a we did we had a club we V
Club for cross your legs Across
America and we were like seriously like
whoever's but people start to drop out
yeah of course they're human beings
I'm stuck on this y'all think
that raw was a classic I'm saying it's
considered a changed people's lives I
have a question for Keith so I was
talking about this with Mark we're
trying to make a Mount Rushmore of
Comedy we're going to leave out people
pre
1980 who's on your Mount
Rushmore pre 1980 no leaving out anybody
so you're out Keith anybody 1980 I'm
never in there I'll go prior calling PR
1980 no they
were yeah they weren't saying they had
to start after 198 yeah they weren't
doing their best work you're allowed to
put you're allowed to put Carlin in PRI
no Carlin did his best work at the in my
opinion after 19 so Cosby I guess always
funny Cosby 83 was himself yeah you can
yeah if you're just talking about skills
like can you put Alisa's
sweater no I say Colin
Cosby prior prior what about being CR or
you said
not prior post 80 is not the best prior
um um um con live and concert is 78 or
something like that how about live in
the Sunset street here and now is in
great PR hold on we need one more from
uh the handicap guy yeah let the
handicap guy stop yeah come on and I'm
going this is going piss people off
Sammy Davis Woody I knew he was going to
say that love it Woody he didn't do
standup after 1980 shut your mouth he's
also 74 let him have this wait a second
he didn't follow your rules at all Woody
Allen has one standup album and it's
still great still holds up guess what
himself Cosby still great still Bill
Cosby himself is the greatest standup
special it's an incredible special two
of your two of your rushmor could be in
jail right now yeah oh Allan and Cosby
War Allan Allan went to trial I shut up
with that Al want to trial [__] he did
and he was declared
innocent who did it not happen who's
seen that what do you mean who he was in
the jury
duty make that show jury duty on Amazon
but it's Woody Allen he's just one of
the jurors
what uh Keith didn't follow your rules
at all but I did what didn't stand up
after 1980 he's saying it's got to be
post 1980 all right post 1980 God you
could say Carlin I got car PR Cosby
who's your fourth Cosby's after 80 yeah
yeah you still Cosby himself is 83 prior
did not do his best work after 1980 shut
up that's who are you to tell you know
what told you what the rule is break
your [__] glass prior always did
great work no Here and Now stinks Here
and Now stinks was always good half of
Sunset Strip is good the other half is
like oh who cares got it's got a lot of
greatness in it though the Jim Brown
story is incredible half of it is great
half of it is who cares and Here and Now
say here and now he's doing jokes about
how cold it is in Chicago still going to
say like prior I want I still got you
can I'm not leaving out prior yeah you
can never leave out prior ever that's
fair we leave you out yeah believe me
I'm
out who's your fourth um my fourth said
Allan you said Woody Allen stand up
after 1980 I'mma go
Rock Chappelle Bill bur
Lou talk about some newer guys I love
Dangerfield I'm so do I but I'm I'mma go
um uh Chappelle Chelle yeah that's fair
even lately you put Chappelle over
Rock for specials
no for comedy yeah interesting well Rock
had two in the 990s that are to me are
unbeatable yeah bring the pain in Bigger
and Blacker are are nuts yeah yeah uh
three years apart by way is still great
yeah yeah all
right what what do you got to say now I
have great respect for Chris I think
he's yeah I think he's very good but I
you're about to say this is where D Roa
goes I think Chris rocks uh work no no
no no I'm not gonna say anything that I
wouldn't say about any comedian it's not
a disrespectful thing I think Chris is
still a great comic I think though there
is a fire you
have on the earlier side of things you
just don't have later which is why I
would say you know do I like anybody's I
don't I I respect the [__] out of
Chappelle you know I don't think Dave's
newer specials are as good as the
earlier ones I think you said that for
most Comics that's what I'm saying I
think Chris is still a great comic but
I'm just I'm just thinking of the newer
specials I'm like that the fire in those
first two and the hunger of like a guy
going I have I have something to [__]
prove right now versus a guy going I I
have nothing to lose I don't care that's
a very different energy I think you're
right I think I think there's uh there's
a need to like like kennison's first
versus his second right's first is
amazing and after that're they're almost
unwatchable well it's it just I think
you have 10 years on that first one or
whatever right well I love Kennis too I
love him but it's
like k [__] you know what eat your
Apple what about what about what about
Mitch Hedberg what no one's talking
about I like Mitch we're talking about
guys passed away I mean Bill Hicks I
think like Five albums and he's dead at
32 is pretty [__] you said a thing
about Bill Hicks though that I I kind of
disagreed with I saw clip what was it it
was a very uh absolute absolutist
statement that anybody that criticizes
him as a [__] idiot or something
my thing with Bill Hicks is this I was a
big big Bill Hicks fan until I became
about
35 and at that point it age I respect
Bill Hicks he's an amazing comic but age
reframed what he did for me and the
older I got the more I started to be
like this feels preachy it feels
condescending it's very much like I'm
right you're wrong and if you don't
agree with me you're a [__] [__] wow
so you stopped liking him 30 years
ago you know and it's like it's like
Carlin start to Teeter into that towards
the very end but like the best parts of
Carlin are when again you you watch
Carlin when Carlin got comfortable
because he was so [__] famous from in
the 70s and he won these Grammys and
everything and he starts in the 80s he
doesn't care anymore he's comfortable
he's doing stuff about peas and all this
[__] and it's boring and then he
gets left out of the conversation and he
gets hungry again and then he comes back
and does like jamming in New York and
back and he's doing these they're
[__] incredible because he gets the
fire again and then that all is very
successful for him and then towards the
end of his life he kind of starts to be
like it's bad for is a good special you
know it's a good special but there's a
lot in it where it's very much matter
effect like if you don't agree with me
you're [__] wrong and you're stupid
and like I don't like
when's I don't like when Hicks gets
condescending but I do think oh when he
gets preachy or pandri whatever but like
just in terms of pure jokes I [__]
love his jokes and and tell said
something about Hicks to me once where
he's like that guy the way Comics will
go to like you know they think they're
like truth tellers or whatever and they
go to San Francisco and uh [__] you
know uh Austin right Hicks was going at
like the reddest part of Alabama and
doing this [__] and I respect that I
respect it I've seen um Hicks in 84 85
oh wow at The Comedy Factory Outland wow
but it wasn't that good really well he
was how he must have been a [__] what
23 or something then yeah really young
are there any women that you would put
on that oh [__] I I have to speak up for
my ladies who do you like who's always
like Wanda Wanda her first one is great
fun as [__] um want whoopy
Goldberg bamford's on mine
bford whoop is a stand think I think of
uh well I know she's more of a solo
artist right does she ever do also
Marsha Warfield is one of my favorites
that no one ever really talks about but
I love like Marsha Warfield was one that
when I saw her doing it she did it the
way that I didn't see
other women doing standup so I it was
very dry it was very like it was just
very it was jokes look look at um look
at up she didn't do that I've never
heard of her but do you saw Night Court
along the lines of what we're talking
about look at Roseanne Roan ranne was
fire when she was broke 20 minutes of
Comedy she had but you see what I'm
saying though then she she gets to
sitcom get money and then it's not funny
anymore she doesn't a anymore got need a
little desperation in my op Eddie Murphy
could struggle going out there because
he's rich and famous and it's not the
same all right no but let me ask you
this
everybody in here if you had the type of
success Murphy had starting out would
you still be popping out special that's
the question look at Jim Carrey look at
all these guys they're all gone I'm
barely I'm barely working at it now I
got a little podcast money I was like
[__] Leno Leno is still going got
millions in the bank I do love the road
I do love touring so it's tough I mean
like [__] Adam Sandler's still [__]
to know Chris Adam doesn't do comedy he
does he does stand up he does he's on
the road const he opens for is he yeah
he does the road constantly same with
rock well that's what's interesting
about a guy that's what's interesting
about a guy like Adam a comic like Adam
versus a comic like
rock the type of Comedy also plays a
factor Adam Sandler can always do Adam
Sandler jokes no matter what kind of
money or what cuz it's it's a it's it's
based in silliness like that's really at
the core is the absurdity of it Chris is
a social commentator so what he's going
to talk about is my favorite parts of
that new special was when he talked
obviously everybody was excited to hear
him talk about the will thing but you
saw like in my opinion you saw like a
vulnerability come out of him again that
I hadn't seen in in a long time called
him a [__] you know like I was like
tambourin the divorce Yeah Tim yeah
that's yeah that's great yeah but but
when you said um
Adam Sandler he didn't have that type of
success that Murphy had right as a
standup yeah Murphy that was a s out
Arenas and all this he got everything up
front yeah biggest movie star good point
you're right it would be hard it would
be and and also back then it must have
been [__] hard I mean you see Steve
Martin's got the quote I quit because of
the Friday Late Show right oh I love
that quote Yeah the best I and he
started playing music he plays his
little uh I did Prairie Home Companion
with Steve really it's amazing um I took
a pH he he was very nice I took a photo
with him the person who was taking the
photo took too long and he was like take
the picture cuz they were just like
taking to long but he was he didn't do
any jokes he was completely into music
did he take the
vCard finally but that's amazing you
guys are forgetting what what's going on
with all these Comics you're naming not
one clean except for Cosby what about
the rean the gaffigans the Seinfeld's
the the other guy well Cosby was clean
Cosby was the only one not clean I'll
name somebody who's not clean who's on
my current top five Cat Williams I think
Cat Williams is a [__] beast so funny
[__] Cat Williams makes me laugh
like from my gut way like I'm like and
for as successful as he is and as I'm
just I'm like this [__] guy just
keeps cranking him out no he's great
godamn this one this special that's his
best
special also don't forget nor
McDonald honorable
mention literally 8 seconds in we're all
laughing yeah and he just looks so he's
4 foot one he's got a hair yeah he's got
a
perm [__] as soon as a [__]
get in trouble now he want to be
surrounded by Muslims and [__] Michael
you ain't no [__] Muslim you
can't even be a Muslim you got a white
pork
face getv Li us and tell [__] don't make
no [__] sense this [__] climbing up
in trees and [__] don't you climb trees
no [__] we got
[Laughter]
build it someone laugh so hard they're
holding their chest
like I've he's pretty good man yeah well
you know what's funny about him is he's
in a pack theater of his fans and he's
still delivering it like he's in a Hell
gig yeah he's sweating and he's bringing
the heat he's yelling do you see anyone
early on Keith where you're like this
dude's not funny and then like years
later you're like that dude's pretty
[__] funny
um Mark is like right here number
one no I mean cuz I know comedy takes
time yeah so you have to be patient uh
but I seen people who I said it wasn't
funny and remain not
funny why did you stare you kind of
stared at me like I felt like you locked
in no no name names I'm not going to
name Nam dude when when I auditioned at
the comic strip they did a [__]
American Idol type of first you two had
my back I don't know if you oh that's
right I was but I remember uh the
[__] Booker of the time tried to be
Simon cow and they were like videotaping
it so he's like just negging me and uh
and he's like I've seen that five
minutes before I killed I remember that
and Marina comes in drunk like [__] you
that's not fair like have my back oh I
did I was out of control Furious and
drunk and on my side and you made me
come back the next week though you got
to do a different five and auditioned
again he was just trying to like they
were trying to tape who was the booker
at the time Jr oh I what I was so drunk
so then I come back the next week and
and the judge one of the judges was
Keith and Keith go Keith like was one of
the judges that passed me through and
then in my seller audition Keith was at
the uh at the table I remember uh I was
[__] nervous as [__] cuz it's like I
2011 I'm terrified and and Keith just
looked at me in front of everyone he
goes look how scared he is and everyone
laugh got a huge Pop I was like [__] I
saw Marina once Marina did a thing you
did a thing at at the strip I always
hated the [__] strip I love the oh I
love theing there good
it's I I really I'm not a fan but anyway
uh they uh you you did thing one night
you you went in and the show was late we
both had spots on like the late show and
you went in and the show was late and
you just
left and I called you and I was like
where'd you go and you're like the
[__] show is 45 minutes late and I'm
not doing this
and just went home and I was like holy
[__] you can do that you just be like go
[__] yourself be a real [__] some
respected the hell out of it I love I
was like yeah because because that was
that was one of the reasons I didn't
like the club that was one of those
clubs when it was late they wouldn't be
like yo sorry we're late it was very
much like tough [__] it's the strip Adam
Sandler performed here 48 years ago okay
great guys you know and I've heard that
story that you've told about you about I
heard heard about Pete Davidson I've
heard it they I just felt like they they
really smelled their own [__] in that
place to be fair every club and I had
some of the best nights of my life there
I also had some of the worst [__]
nights I think though to be fair to Jr
um just a little I do like Jr and the
thing is is I think he didn't understand
the seriousness and the gravity of what
he was doing he was just having fun and
I KN I remember that night I was just
angry that he didn't understand how
important this was for you guys yeah so
that's why I was like no no he was being
a disc he was being a disc well he was
there's no room for that [__] there's no
room for a Booker to [__] do that to
they no they don't all do that no they
don't but you know what no they don't no
they don't end of the day though it did
[__] prepare me for the business like
that that type of shittiness where
you're like EST at the seller can be can
be course and candid but she don't do
[__] like that true no she would never
be like but but that's what well Jr was
not really supposed to be the booker one
book one Booker number everybody with
Chris Rock once when Lucian at from the
comic Tri passed away and and in the
thing Rock said well he passed this
person instead of me and I was like that
never goes away no that never goes I
never well no look you're not just told
me said look team you used to be funny
now you're just fat and
Jolly Jolly has he met you what the [__]
he never held that huh you never held
that no I don't because I'm like all
right what I'm saying and what I'm
saying is is that's harsh but it was a
real criticism that he felt at the time
it might not be T to call me fat I'm
saying though but you see what I'm
saying what Jr did to you a Booker has
no [__] place doing that he deserved
it know you're all right I like Jr Jr
really I don't know why anyone but it's
funny or not funny what do fat and jolly
have to do with comedy I know I know but
you know gnome had asked me once what
makes a Booker like a good like what
makes someone know and become a Booker
and I go well and why do you Comics go
to I go we go to whoever CU we know that
the person who's sweeping up the room
could eventually be the booker right and
that was Jr yeah so Jr didn't he knew he
didn't know J he was just playing the
role and then
yeah and then yeah it was off a lot of
he's stuck at being a
janitor he's Bart Ting again now by the
way he back that's a strip oh really
he's behind the bar I'm going to go get
a drink and not tip people
hat four hinin
thanks they used to have free drinks
there remember that free drinks that was
H rip Vic Henley every he was a j oh he
was mean to you young guys I like I got
I like VI a lot some people he didn't
like well I liked his energy every night
two shots of Patron yeah every night
just drunk [__] at the bar cracking me
love Yeah Vic Vic I miss Vic he was a
good hang yeah it's very few people I
didn't like yeah it was well there's a
lot that don't like you
Keith except
you no used to always put my
ex-boyfriend in check though he goes
you're not as funny as her and you
should know it oh he would always do
that so that's why I that's pretty funny
yeah he was like and you're not as funny
as her damn
yeaha well yeah it was nice that he put
him in his place for me he cucked
him how did what did Vic die from a
heart
attack I don't know something some sort
of leg thing like a clot or something in
his leg anur he got hit by a car I think
he was drunk and then uh oh [__] all
right P Vic I heard Jr killed him
JR damn he made three Comics judges
killing too Luan told me when I audition
for Luan Luan took me in the office and
he
goes he goes I close my eyes I hear Big
Jay and he goes and look at what you're
wearing clearly you don't care about
your
appearance he did that to me at the
comic Bob wax did that to me he goes
you're dressed like [__] he's wear a
[__] polo shirt for God's sake damn
like dude Luan told me he was like well
I can uh sort of believe that you have
the continent of Africa on the the top
of your head um but it seems guy should
have been a comic he goes you do a good
British act I think I can place the area
from Britain or England where you're
doing it and if I did hire you I could
kill like two birds with you know one
stone so I was like he was great for
those little moments no I love Lucian he
was you know he was a funny comedy
seller I mean a comedy comic strip one
down after him passed interesting you
need a good Booker it's like it really
is he need somebody who gives a [__]
means the Hang is good loves
comedy Lucian loved comedy yes more than
his family even I remember even as he
was passing away I would go to his house
and take care of his cats and stuff and
he was like I could give this to my
family but they're not worth
it and he just he but he loved comedy he
wanted to be around it all the time he
had the smile just seeing people do well
there he is very 80s I started there I
think right after we passed I thought it
was Freddy Mur oh you
there uh yeah my first week at the
Sellar I was terrified and Keith you
were hosting believe it or not this is
how long ago this was and you brought me
up as Jerry Seinfeld the crowd went nuts
they're all going crazy and you go I'm
just kidding it's this guy and I [__]
ate it what the [__] is the matter with
you man the [__] is the matter with you
no is the matter with you well somebody
else some of a star probably stopped in
I brought them up and then once once
like I say Dave Chappelle and then if
somebody they waiting for somebody else
right I'm like all right you got GRE we
got more yeah you got more that's why I
did it
I thought it was like a lesson no no no
oh okay it's not like what you used to
do you used to host you used to end on
this one joke and you never considered
the fact that I was next oh here we go
when you would go women [__] up fun all
the time men we laugh women you [__] up
fun your next comment come to the stage
Mar and I would
go I was too young to address it but you
didn't know it was like you could see
them going home women do [__] up fun I
remember bringing my dad to The Cellar
one night and and I don't know if I ever
seen him laugh quite as hard as when
Keith was hosting marina gets off stage
and he goes I used to date her and she
wears granny panties he said no he used
to say I she wore the worst
panish peard worst she used to have a
bucket of panties in the middle of the
room and she just pick one out and then
I'd have to go on after that and have to
explain it so then I have to talk about
my
panties and uh and I made a whole bit
about my I tried to take my power back
by talking about my own panties right
right like the
nword oh he would stand in the doorway
when I was you would stand in the
doorway when I was on stage the seller
just go
yes I feel like we're talking about ke
like he's dead I know right here I'm
here
guys Keith has gotten Keith has gotten
soft Keith has gotten soft who had two
strokes you think that's
what I was about to say The Strokes made
you soft yes that's I can barely talk
yeah good he can barely talk and he's
putting out more specials in
youing it's a good point I remember I
called you when you were in the hospital
and or uh your your uh your son's mom
called me uh the hospital she goes she
goes hi Joe I'm just calling cuz I'm
here with ke Keith and he's co she goes
he's coherent he can't speak but he
would love to just hear your voice and I
go okay cool and she put me on speaker
phone I go can you hear me and she goes
yes and I go I'm glad you can't talk sit
there and shut your [__] mouth for
what you know was she horrified or did
she get it uh she laughed and and he was
like going
like well the thing when I could
talk the nurse was the speech
pathologist was in there she said well
you know you got to practice your words
say them over and over again I said I
got it let me make a call and I call
Robert Kelly he said hey what's up dude
I'm like Bob's a f
[Laughter]
[__] and it got better after that too it
worked yeah it got better Liz said you
Liz said you gu you said to her Marina
is a
cun
cuz Arena took over no the I only did
what the family everyone said I was in
control Arena came became Lucian and
Jr she was booking my my hospital I was
like you can't just leave alone right
now but I was also like going by what
your baby's mom was saying don't call
her baby mom children's
Mother the uh no the the the the the cuz
you said when you had the first stroke I
remember I said how did you I said how
did you get your because he drove
himself to the hospital as the stroke
was happening and I go how did you do it
he goes I summoned all my
evil but the bounce back cuz both
Strokes I I talked to you like pretty
early on after it happened through
recovery and like you're bounce back to
who you are truly at your core evil yes
it was so
instantaneous the the first show was
faster but I'm saying you even at your
in your most incapacitated State during
either stroke you still like thought it
was funny if we trashed you about it
like like that's what I mean you're
resolve it's it's incredible to me that
like you you kept like your sense of
humor through all of it like there was
never a part of you where you were like
no dude like I'm not in a head space for
that kind of humor now like you were
yourself constantly that would make me
sick I've said that that would make me
so it would have been understandable
though I'm not my head fair I'm just
saying it would not have been like crazy
if you had would been like okay you
imagine Keith being like I'm triggered
right now this is really offensive well
that's why he's the real deal because
every comic in Brooklyn would make this
a oneperson show and they would milk the
[__] out of it and they would have a
whole special about how sad it is you're
going to go up there and talk about
[__] you know
I assume that is true yes yes yeah Keith
would have live tweeted his tragedic
journey and all this [__] and you know
right and there would have been article
please I've asked you this before please
interview me for the part where you you
interview comics in your special we have
to talk about how great you are and how
good it's to see you back on your please
interview me first person I want them to
talk to about my
magnificence I just realized this is
real [__] I realized like through school
and all that I don't know how you guys
wasn't school but I was an [__] all
through school elementary junior high I
picked on so many people it's like oh
[__] I seen a video of this girl
introducing me you know she said this
guy picked on me she was a um a d DJ she
is a DJ and um Philadelphia WDS M but I
picked on her so much in school she
introduced me a while back I seen a
video of it uh and she said this guy
messed with me said I I was fat and this
and that and he's a horrible comic Keith
Robinson oh [__] but I realized how many
people I [__] with in school and I
thought I was a good guy God
cuz I never you know felt any you know
but I'm like guys who I said was gay and
all this they all turned out to be gay
but and just you're a fortune teller
yeah no but you were trying to steer him
in the right direction trying to
help the but he goes now they all turned
out to be gay
but but I was in second grade I
that's different you know what I'm
saying is just like tell the Ralph
Harris story when Ralph Harris first
started doing comedy and why his family
hates you
oh haris started like I started 84 he
started
85 and he said what I what do I do to
make it in this business and do what I
need to do I said well get yourself some
knee
fats all right and I left without that
this ass brought himself knee pads oh
jeez and then they people told him what
it
was at the store they laughed and his
whole family was mad at me that's
nothing it was just because you know he
get to blow
people but he was his family tried to
trip me and all that whoa yeah well cuz
when he went to get the knee pads I
think at the store right the guy behind
the counter he said why are you getting
he or he told him he was getting CU he
was starting comedy and the guy just
started laughing oh my God he he
understood he understood more than El
did that's hilarious isar come on but
you do do that to people yeah now he
talk now he does but he still has a
little bit of a even you know Patrice
used to say that he goes everyone thinks
Keith is
sweet I no do we and then Patrice is
like and I get it yeah Patrice got it
cuz he had a bigger mouth yeah I miss I
whisper something to him and they send
out I missed the um because we used to
go I don't think I don't know if you
guys you guys probably never went I
missed the Patrice barbecues those were
like you know I heard about them it was
it was just like the most legendary like
trashing from the second you showed up
to the second you left I mean it was so
R remember when Raman Harris came and he
he had a hat on he took it off and he
haded a mohawk that was died blood we
kept calling him Demolition Man and like
he like eventually like wa like he like
went and sat in like the corner
like and the way that's the thing you
guys missed yeah the the back table
trash yeah we showed up after why do you
think that went away cuz that's Patrice
died that's whyat died you know yeah I
had a couple of
strokes but it also too the culture
changed it was like it just became thing
where like it was like the the as as the
mainstream form of Comedy started to
become less the cool form and the cooler
version of it was be the Brooklyn thing
was seeping more into the
mainstream the idea
of hazing just became un sort of UNC
yeah I tried it that and the generation
would start crying being hazed by by
your by comedians who you liked was
different than being hazed to me like a
Booker who you didn't give a [__] about
you know yeah that's a different thing
no yes but it was it was it was I
remember when I first moved here I lived
with
oerson I remember like and again Keith
Keith and b i ow I I I'm not being
modlin I I really I owe so much to Keith
to Bobby I helped you to Marina I was
about to say you you [__] insecure
ass let me get to you God damn it to
Marina um like they they be I remember I
was in Jay in the apartment that Jay and
I lived in and I was so depressed and I
was like they all these guys make fun of
me and whatever oh so it did get to you
it did and and he called Keith and
Keith's like we do it cuz we like you
stupid and he named like four comics and
he goes you ever hear us talk about them
and I go no and he goes exactly we like
you dummy we see Talent you and and it
was if if there was a mark of acceptance
if you got trashed so as much as it
sucked walking into like that murderer's
row of which it truly I hate that
expression but it truly was it was like
you would go into the cell it was doollo
Keith Judy Burr
Geraldo uh uh Patrice it Norton Colin
well no and it was like you would just
get [__] eviscerated if your shirt
sucked whatever whatever some of them
wasn't messing with people like that it
was me with trees
Voss Voss Norton y Robert Kelly wasn't
mess with people like Bobby used to
trash me constantly he was handsome Bob
when Bob was handsome bom nothing I met
him at the beginning of chunky yeah fat
B beginning a junkie Fat Bob is funnier
than thin Bob yeah I feel like fatter is
always funnier yeah I miss Fat Bob yeah
fat and jolly I don't know about this
Bob I'm glad I'm glad he's not this Bob
is trying to be the B looks like Brando
and Apocalypse Now what the
[__] is that picture there Jesus Christ
there a ceiling fan going slowly above
him what the heck happened there yeah he
looks good there yeah what a h go go to
that bottom one though holy [__] no to
the to the left yeah yikes that's Brando
later years the other one that yeah
clearly yeah y I missed that guy that's
a funnyy I want Fat Bob back I'm sorry
he'll get there don't worry he'll be
back back why you talking like he's not
coming back we all know he's it's like
saying
ah I wish that guy would go back to
heroin he will don't
worry give us some time the uh but
Marina Marina you said to me uh at the
at the when we used to the shows at the
Boston and you used to have your own
show you were the person that said to me
and I was saying this early about Burr
and Marina was the other person said
them you said why don't you why don't
you just be truthful about your
insecurities I said
yeah and it changed like that was such a
great honest time because you you
whether whether somebody was your friend
or somebody you looked up to or whatever
everybody was so honest like with each
other it was brutal I mean it would make
you want to
cry way that's that's not brutal that's
like that's her being helpful no but
it's like in this day and age you can't
you can if you you got a really tiptoe
you got a tiptoe around these Comics
like they don't
careful like I I have gotten in trouble
with some of the younger Comics they
think I'm mean really yeah you are me
mar I I was just doing what you guys
used to do or I would tell them what I
would tell you or whatever and I could
see the the water welling up in their
eye I was like what's what's going on
here or or they'd be like can can you
not can you just not do that and I'd be
like oh my God what's happening yeah
just I this is where this is what how
you get better is you learn from people
who came before I was trying to sexually
assault you and I don't know why you're
being so uptight about
it pretty well I heard a guy I'm not
going to say who but he said the word
[__] at the table and some another comic
goes all right easy with the language I
was like I'll tell you after I'll tell
you after I like why can't you say who
said [__] why is that bad you don't have
you don't have to rat out who
reprimanded them I'll say let me
say [__]
but it was I was I remember sitting
there and I was like whoa this is weird
you can't even say [__] at the table
even having a guy back then like Todd
Lynn who's gone uh who I I've I I had
such such
insane clashes with Wayne St New York
Wayne Raa pulled us outside and he goes
I will ban both of you from this [__]
club if you don't stop was not a friend
like we were screaming at each other
like I I got into to like Titanic
[__] clashes with that guy but cuz he
picked on me pushed my and then later
when he got sick he he still had the
greatest slam I've ever received ever in
my life oh hit me when he was blind he
walked up to we were at Montreal we were
flying home I was sitting at the gate
and he walked up he was blind he had two
canes and he goes he goes h d Ro is that
your awful voice I hear and I go yeah
Todd and he goes g and I go I got to be
honest Todd I would have thought you
getting sick would have softened you up
a little bit and he goes just cuz I'm
blind doesn't mean you can't offend my
other
senses even on the way out he was that
like a three you know yeah that's a swi
buzzer good even having him around and
Todd pissed off a lot of people oh yeah
yes and he would be proud of it he'd be
like I'm a [__] villain that's my
that see you don't know that what you
are like like he was such a [__] [__]
about it um but it was good it was like
all right you got this guy around it
kind of keeps you on your toes a little
bit it's [__] frustrating but it was
it was I don't know there was something
about being able to have a guy like that
around where it wasn't like this this
this federal case that it's almost like
the internet where they used to be
Gatekeepers and it was hard to get on TV
now there's the internet so you can put
anything you want on YouTube yeah we
need gers but we need a little of them
in the middle guy basketball podcast I
forgot what player I think it was Kevin
Garnett said uh in the NBA now it's
worse than it was in the 90s cuz they
got rid of the they got rid of the goons
and they kept the bullies oh it's great
and I feel like the same goes for comedy
where it's like you need some of those
dudes yeah you do CU you don't want too
many but you don't want too little you
need some midd ground what what are you
going to do you're going to walk in the
corner and you're going to go that guy's
a [__] [__] right well the goons
keep the bullies in check you need goons
yeah yeah I mean but there were I liked
um all that I like
Patrice even
depalo yeah they were they were good for
each other goons Patrice and depalo
though had a had a genuine Todd never I
mean godamn dude Todd was well Todd was
whatever and sometimes people got their
feelings hurt and they would apologize
later like Patrice would actually call
someone up like when he when Angelo was
at the table at the comedy sellers table
comedian Angelo lzada who
[Music]
Angelo is the sweetest man in the world
and he came to the seller table when you
really could not sit there unless you
were a comic and someone who was
managing told him he had to get up and
he was so offended he ran out and or
Patrice started laughing no no no oh
okay he said y'all yall going to let
this happen
oh yep
we we took the son you know he had a
little little placard yeah put it in his
face beat it the sign said comedy seller
comedians only it used to sit on the
table which is no longer there but I've
seen I've seen people throw that in in
people's faces before in my earlier cell
years EST used to do it to me when I sat
at the table like hanging out would go
like that it was so [__] funny though
I was like all right I'll [__] it wasun
my point is though Patrice when Angelo
ran out cuz he was so upset Patrice ran
after him grabbed cuz he L run out
nobody he did he loved Angelo and he
apologized to he was like he was like
you know I have I love that stuff so he
did he took he loved Angelo this is how
sweet Angelo was this is how sweet when
Angelo was sick yeah because he he had
cancer and I think he got diagnosed at
like stage four he got diagnosed late
stomach can I didn't know he was sick I
had no idea and I saw him said he looked
good he thin yeah and I go I go dude you
look [__] great what are you working
out and he's like you know poy just
living you know I'm doing and then like
a week later somebody was like you know
Angelo has like stage fork and I was
like Jesus Christ man he's on his death
Joe's like dude you're looking he so
gracious that he wasn't like going to be
like dude I'm sick like he just was like
thanks buddy I appreciate that like like
like nor McDonald yeah it's wild man he
was a really ni guy but yeah Patrice I
Lov Angelo whenever he would he would
host a Gotham all the time he was like
just good energy man funny dude
supportive and encouraging not he was
the opposite of all those guys he was
very encouraging to younger Comics like
in a way that he helped you with your
bits he told you what was funny he told
you what was good about you just all
around just wonderful human being nobody
did that [__] H you you want them to get
better
smash but some people weren't I saw Ted
Alexander who I looked up to and Patrice
with the seller I was super green I I
stayed away but Ted sat down at the
table and Patrice goes look at this
[__] sweater what the hell and Ted
just got up and walked away and I was
like oh I didn't know we could do that I
don't know you could just get up and
leave he he was like I'm an adult you
going to make fun of my outfit I'm
leaving when you break it down like that
it does sound yeah it blew my mind I was
like Oh I thought you just had to get
yelled at it for half an hour it's like
any it's like anything else of course
it's like anything else you take the
good with the bad like it's like of
course it went too far sometimes of
course it was unnecessary of course at
times it was juvenile but overall I felt
like the good that came from it was
could be constructive if you if you were
willing to take the time yourself to fil
to sort of filter through what was being
said and what the the value of what but
everybody got it though everybody nobody
was Sting there
untouched yeah everybody got it if you
were in you got it if you weren't in you
didn't get it which is what why I found
value in it I was like I'm part of this
I'm getting [__] it is hilarious to be
like you're one of us you ugly piece of
[__] the best part of that time too was
that like Patrice and those guys made
fun of younger Comics who were coming in
and also liked these younger Comics not
all of them but for the most part like
Patrice when he did his document his uh
video for his his uh roast or whatever
he wanted to include Like Comics that
weren't yet passed and nowadays you kind
of see like a separation where it's like
these are the good Comics these are the
struggling Comics these are the ones who
aren't past you stay over there you stay
over there when Patrice would always
like he would trash you but he would say
come on over here and be a part of this
true so that was what was good about it
and I don't know if you have that now
yeah it's a good point it's like
inclusivity know say it but it's all
[__] do you feel like Patrice was
like really captured in his specials cuz
I feel like elephant in the room he was
but I feel like this other stuff that
wasn't like didn't cap as good as he was
what are the other like his half hours
or like stuff like that well he got what
happened I think as he went
along he seen what didn't work like he
didn't love his um half hour hm right
but the woman from
hm I she had told me I I'll never book
him again really you know and
um like Bill Bill Burr and Patrice did
the special the same night I watched
that I was there and Bill Clean House
Billy kill I remember when I saw that
that night billya great Billy killed in
a way where I was like holy [__] this
guy's about to be like
remember that half hour the brunch bit
is that pesto that bill that thing he
ended with the thing about going to MLK
to see the black girl dat and I was like
this [__] guy Danny Glover Boulevard
yeah like
holy
sold um Bar's um half hour to commedy
Central but they didn't buy
patri and that kind of hurt a little bit
so the trees for the elepant the room
put everything in it and he called me
like hey what are they saying in the
barber
shops cuz I told him like Hey and the
barber shop was talking is popping yeah
so he said what are they
saying they giving it a thumbs up right
[__] and that was elephant in the room
yeah yeah that was a great special yeah
yeah so he he he couldn't go down on
that one like I'm not going down I mean
my my mom likes
Patrice my mom's religious she doesn't
like when he talks about [__] and all
that stuff that's too much that's too
graphic but she anything else he does my
mom likes patri like
Patrice it it was he was doing a
universal strangely for his polarizing
was doing a very Universal uh in my
opinion was undeniable when when you're
that funny it's like did enjoy him
walking people out of comedy clubs I
have to say I haven't seen anyone do it
l way Patrice would upset like a man
with his wife he'd be like she's got you
like this look at you and I remember a
guy just standing up he's like and he
was in almost in tears he's like you
can't say that about me and he goes I
just did and the guy just storms out he
goes come on and it just you see the I
like there's an I know it's
dysfunctional and I know it's not like
good but there was an art to that that I
completely loved but I think that it you
know when he did that special he had
learned a lesson that you
know this one had to be it for yes he
could not mess up on this one I saw it
was a I saw him at Carolines he did a
joke about the T it was when the tsunami
happen he did a joke about the Tsunami
he opened the joke I remember this joke
yeah and he goes that didn't look that
bad look like if you pulled your pants
up you'd
be these people from England walked I've
never seen anything like this he within
like 48 seconds or something of stepping
on stage he walked three people that
were in the country from England
visiting they went to the bar I was out
I think I opened for him that's why I
was there or maybe I just might have
been watching but I I was sitting at the
bar while I was on stage they walked out
and they said sat there and bitched
about him for two [__] hours how
offended they were and how they were
waiting for him and they
waited just to verbally accost him when
he came out after the show that's how
mad they were but Patrice never looked
upset he always smile he was drag they
were they got so aggressive with him
that they drugg the security was like
dragging them basically or shoving them
up the stairs at Carolines and as they
were doing it the woman goes you're an
embarrassment to America
and the guy secur goes all right you got
to go miss it was that guy Eddie Patrice
goes no man this is
fun well he famously said that if 50% of
the audience loves you and 50% hates you
you're doing the right thing which
whenever I have a underpar set I just
tell myself that like ah 50% hated me
I'm like Patrice but everybody in there
though has a load of that you do and you
do but I see you guys you CH take the
chances yeah to you know oh I walked
some people last night it's good every
once in a while you got to walk you
can't always have everybody all in right
you got to walk some and I I get upset
when people walk out still I do too but
I do to because it's not my intention
and I'm
like I don't know I feel like if you're
just listening with an open mind nobody
needs to walk out but it happens and I'm
always I still have that thing in where
I'm like all right I guess yeah you
can't expect every crowd to like you
when you and when you do a shitload of
sets every once in a while it's okay you
know right yeah yeah as long as your
motives aren't to like [__] embarrass
someone well you said something about
rape one time you'll have to be more
specific yeah you got in trouble yeah
you got in trouble for for that one it's
such a joke a clear joke that's what's
crazy well you know people if if you're
looking for [__] to be upset about you
could find it pretty easily with any of
our acts so true I mean there was
nothing was said in any malice it's just
you know people are [__] bored and
this is like this is their form of
entertainment I'm upset I'm going to
write a blog and then you're like enjoy
but I'm I'm going to write something
back and we'll and we'll do this little
dance for a second that's it I'm that
way I'm that way in real life like like
I was saying I was at the kiss show we
kept walking out of our seats me and
Paul tell you kept walking out of our
seats because we were cuz my friend Nick
was trying to get us closer to the stage
and this whole thing but these people
that were sitting at the end of our row
were getting really mad and I'm like
they're in the seventh row at the
[__] kiss show on the floor at M we
got our tickets for free they probably
paid like five grand for these [__]
seats I felt bad and I went up to the
guy and I go listen man I'm not trying
to ruin your night do take our seats
they're better you they're in the center
and we'll take yours and we won't walk p
and he goes good [__] [__] you get the
[__] back and I was like no D no no no
no no no no I'm trying to tell you I'm
just and he goes get the [__] back to
you and and Paul was like Joe walk away
but that's how I feel with the audience
sometimes I'm like no no I wasn't trying
to hold on a second hold on and they're
like no we don't want to hear and I'm
like right okay I guess so man like it's
not my intention like I just wanted it
gives me joy this him this uh this needs
shoulder pads a there we go
am I getting too sincere sorry no no
you're good but I know what you mean
though dud [__] whiskey I people are
looking for [__] to be angry about
there's a lot of people well can I
change gears and go into peeves real
quick sure right on that do I have AET
peeves oh we do told what is this the
the Paul verie podcast the bone to pick
part of our thing so does anyone have
any pet PE well everyone here has them
yes what do you got what do you got oh
my pet peeve is J
going to say that you're going to say
that Joe what do you like better Santa
Claus out of Easter Bunny and [__] when
you do that oh wait you are you talking
about my podcast yes it annoys the [__]
out of me all right all he like ginger
snaps on chocolate chip cookies shut the
[__] up tast bus all right I tell you
what I'll buy you something nice with
the money I
make get him a new cane
watch taste buds folks a show that Keith
Robinson will never be
on I can't pronounce most of this [__]
what do you prefer Keith Viagra or
seis Let's do an episode no man see
Alice man Keith stroke number one or
stroke number two let's have it you got
to go with stroke number
two [__] that's hilarious we should
probably wrap this [__] all right all
right plug in plug some dates where you
going to be you got a website oh yes so
um December 16th I'm going to be at the
City
Winery headlining in The Loft at the
Winery so then just uh go to
the still Stacks in February Christmas
oh we Stacks in February if I had known
I would have worn a festive shirt
um steel Stacks in February I can't
remember oh steel Stacks is a good room
in uh P Pennsylvania sorry is it not on
my calendar it's in February okay you're
in January sorry look at look at that
body that I used to have is going to
light you up oh you know what I haven't
put it there sorry you know what just go
and check out my podcast uh friends like
us or you could also for the holidays
everybody check out single black female
I'm I'm talking about woke pre uh taking
over the woke W all
righto they stole woke they they
weaponized it yeah there you go white
people steal
everything
SC scroll up sorry just oh yeah yeah uh
all right folks thanks for having me on
the show guys uh I'm on my I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden Tour 2024
January 13th New York New York at the
grar theater I'm doing Austin Texas the
old Mothership there four shows January
19th and 20th uh of January then after
that uh Nashville and February Charlotte
San Fran West Hollywood San Diego and
then in March palade Califor Palmdale
sorry California Portland Oregon Seattle
Washington for all tickets and all uh uh
show info ticket links whatever go to
jar rosa.com please and please come on
down to Joey roses Jo Joey Ros bar.com
get yourself a sandwich guys Springfield
Missouri uh Madison Dania Beach
Philly uh some other [__] I can't read
that's real tour
Joe Dallas when's the special Oklahoma
City Omaha [__] Knuckles will toy
your special in uh Boston March I
believe 7th and 8th or 8th and 9th I
can't read that [__] but it's sam.com
and uh new special coming soon folks
yeah Mark Norman comedy
you can see the dates coming to shreport
and uh [__] Phoenix looks so sad next
Austin Raleigh Atlanta Salt Lake City
you you name it Tucson El Paso
Albuquerque Memphis Little Rock
Knoxville Chattanooga Syracuse yeah Mark
get some Bodega cat Bodega cat
whiskey.com folks uh thanks for
listening we love you have a Merry
Christmas yeah my special this the 19
yeah sorry did I I just stepped on you
closing out your own pocket I'm so sorry
good no you're not you're not sorry no I
am sorry I I just I feel
like do a clip we'll do Clips we'll do
Clips to plug Keith now we [__] up I
thought this was I thought this is
coming out earlier 17th yeah oh oh this
is after his special oh good we'll plug
it we'll plug it on social we're going
to sell it out that's all right man
nobody cares what about the p
well we R out of time unless you got one
give us a peeve I do I have several but
um give us one my pet peeve is when my
super mops the floor from the fifth and
he leaves the water on the floor and
then he goes back up to mop it Oh weird
that's a weird I was a janitor that's a
bad my pet peeve like if you mop the
floor like dry it
immediately you got to Sue this guy you
I had an argument with Pito
recently about this so please if you do
this make sure it's dry for papito's
listening yeah pet PE Peto gives me
a I'm peeved at your pep why there I
could fall and I'll sue all right all
right there you go thanks for listening
guys Papito we got you someone to suck
on there
dude appreciate beard Thank You Salon
Matt Peters Merry Christmas we love you
guys we might be drunk happy
[Music]
holidays a lot of them on the good list
this year so I'm going to have to
deliver some more presents it was
wonderful to see you oh even
you all right someone plug in Kevin
space and
GPS little boy so you got the original
sweat shop over there in the North Pole
huh yes it's been very nice uh it's nice
cheap labor and um you just have to feed
them some milk and cookies that I take
from the houses that I come to so it's
pretty quite easy a lot of people think
that I eat them but now instead I bring
them so I can get some free labor you
know I just remember when I was a kid I
saw you [__] my
mom yes that was very
nice D have a wonderful wonderful
Christmas okay Merry Christmas